mhm come on come on Magnus please go
Knight h8 just for the for the culture
for the for the memes you know and he
does hey and Knight G5 fukaru is not
stopping there yeah Knight G5 is the
natural followup and I think we might
get to a situation where uh the bishop
drops back to f8 guards G7 you kind of
admit that you can't keep guarding F7
but no D4 he wants to clarify the center
and maybe pick up that B Pawn what's
mesmerizing about this game is how both
players are using the board as their
cannabis they're like two artists
painting on the left side and in the
middle and Hikaru striking everywhere
but Magnus look at the defensive
construction that he has adopted on the
king side it's it would survive a
nuclear
apocalypse and truly let's not forget
the bishop is also defending the B Pawn
so if pieces start to trade it's
actually going to be Magnus of all
people who walks away saying I actually
might play for a win I'm not a big
soccer fan but when people describe
watching lonel Messi I've heard it
described you think that you have more
more than 11 men on your field when you
watch Magnus and hikaro handling their
pieces you almost feel like they have
more pieces on the board to start with
they've like found a cheat code watch
out though if you're Carlson Bishop back
to f8 I think a repetition of moves is
likely Hikaru he has enough compensation
for the pawn in the form of his
incredible pie activity he goes for it
though he Caro playing for a win here
but I don't really see a future in this
position and he does
yeah he does and that's all that matters
you know exactly
I think long term the most that he could
hope for with everything so defended on
the king side is yeah he can win the bwn
but it will trade a pair minor pieces
and you know the Knight on h8 as silly
as it looks is actually an amazing
defend what Knight on H and now it's
Magnus goes for it he says you let my
knight back in the game I'm going to
make you pay for it but now there's a
rink pressure and I think we're going to
get liquidation and finally a draw now
guaranteed yeah a draw guaranteed but
you know the most moral of Victories for
Magnus having the Knight against the
bishop it's like haha and that was a
real test for Magnus because he was
under pressure from the early middle
game Hikaru did some great stuff on the
queen side and every time that Magnus
had to find an important move to stay a
float he did he found D5 he found Knight
h8 he arranged his pieces perfectly and
Magnus is just indicating that he is in
phenomenal form yet again he is um I
mean Kar Nakamura is step for step with
him but just to be able to do that on
defense is very very impressive Magnus
letting his clock run down there to like
1 second but now he builds it back up
and is he like playing for a win here to
be a little bit careful King
H1 Knights are are tricky pieces and
with the King cut off here this is not
this is not nothing I've played Magnus
in enough bullet games to know that he
can win with no pieces on his clock and
hikaro he seems annoyed I I don't know
what he's annoyed about this is still a
draw me I'm wondering as well whether
it's like he's annoyed with himself for
having to be the one defending or whoa
huh whoa whoa whoa whoa what what is
going on
here we're seeing some kind of pre moves
and maybe that was the reaction he pre
moved Bishop F2 or
something but wait Magnus is black here
he gave up a
bishop wait what on Earth hekaru could
have captured that immediately and won
the game I think he must have pre moved
it which is why he's like just thinking
to himself I can't believe I just played
so quickly we're going to have to do an
instant replay after this game
finishes
unbelievable nothing to say after that I
thought that it was a glitch him on I
thought that the board lagged or
something but no it didn't Magnus had
made a false pre-move and Hikaru had
responded with a pre-move instead of
capturing that free
Knight that was so strange but here we
are in this position trying to play
Bishop f8 uh let's be clear even after
uh that well let's call it a a blunder
is what it was initially it would have
been immediately lost for Magnus but
when he did win the piece it was at the
cost of both of his pawns so yeah I
think this is actually going to be a
draw anyway and there's just no way to
make progress that's the whole point if
both pawns disappeared this game would
last for another couple hours but as it
stands that King on G6 is on a perfect
defensive position Magnus did a great
job of adjusting you know he blundered
that piece but he didn't Panic he found
the only narrow path to a draw and again
I will point out for the 100,000 of you
in the chat were sitting there thing I
didn't see what happened like what on
Earth just happened why did isaro up a
minor piece we will quickly revisit that
moment and try to explain retroactively
what happened yeah right now it's uh
it's all about this rook and Bishop whoa
whoa Magnus is playing so sloppy here
Rook B7 he's blundered the gun yeah he
got idea and he had Rook a eight there I
think but he's just doing everything
possible to give fukar winning
chances yeah that's true Rook A8 is a is
a good spot but hang on that pawn will
most I think you could probably find a
way in 50 moves to to win that pawn what
do you think Daniel I think you could
surround it eventually I there are a
bunch of fortresses with Rook pawn and
King against Rook bishop and King and
this might be one of them this might be
a situation where as long as you keep
the Rook on A6 hear actually has no way
to surround the F6 but I'm not sure yeah
it it almost feels like one of those uh
you know potential worst case scenarios
for hikaro where he's played you know so
well and what is he going to come out of
this with just another draw like he's
itching to get that one full point
converted because he's had so many
opportunities just not quite enough in
terms of an
evaluation man but this would be so huge
if something crazy happens and Magnus
blunders the pawn and loses the the
subsequent end game that would be so
would be that would decisively change
the momentum and the tenor of this match
so Magnus has to keep his his his
annoyance in check hikaro just continues
to you know make those motions I I mean
I would be happy that I even have the
extra Bishop to begin
with I mean what what's going on here
yeah the the players are reacting to
something so it's like I can't wait to
see what it is what it is
yeah I'm wondering if there yet another
blender because they have too much time
to be flagging yeah I mean if white
blenders The Rook he actually loses
because black has the F
Pawn maybe the bishop got blundered and
then now it's Magnus pushing with one
Pawn oh what
what what just happened we need so many
instant replays right now well clearly
we got teleported into the future we
were lagging on like 20 moves and those
20 moves were made and Magnus lost the
the game before the next game starts we
have to look over what happened I need
to at least go back to where that pawn
Was Won how was
lost I don't know how that even occurred
it's just a dead Fortress hearu went
around the side he went around the side
and somehow amazing he somehow got the
pawn and then he won it that's
incredible that's truly incredible
insane and then I'm going to fast
forward cuz they played so many moves
they just coming instantly I'll just
show the finish of this bishop and
Knight or uh sorry bishop and Rook they
used to don't have that many pieces
didn't get the memo on it was
blundered and and then wow oh my gosh
stopping from going to A5 and I mean I'm
not even sure what just happened there
are we on to the next game I'm looking
for the next game here I don't think we
are just yet um I think maybe the
players are are adjusting to this new
reality I have so many questions and not
enough answers first of all what Magnus
had no business pre-moving with four
seconds on the clock in that night he
got too comfortable I think being in the
driver seat of that end game and then
suddenly he gives up the Knight then he
gives up one Pawn then another one and
then the thing we haven't talked about
he actually lost rook and Bishop versus
Rook which for newer players is a
theoretical draw which means with best
play you are supposed to be able to make
a draw but there's no one better than
Hikaru at squeezing WIS quite like this
one yeah and for more experienced
players it's a theoretical draw as well
um just so you know Magnus would make it
in a classical game he he would the
thing about what we just witnessed is
you know we could say whatever we want
about oh you know he car pre moved he
missed that free piece let's focus on
what actually did happen he he actually
played a game against Magnus and he won
rook and Bishop against rook in two
pawns it feels like oh he's got the that
extra piece yeah he always had winning
chances no that is so dead drawn it's
actually incredible that he was able to
win that and not in my wildest dreams
what I think Magnus of all people could
lose that position you needed a momentum
boost as hiar Nakamura you just got it I
would not to be the Debbie Downer of the
party as as we see the next game
underway and I just think we see it in
magnus's body language he might still be
incredulous he might just think I I I'm
going to wake up from this any moment
now but the reality is he's still up a
point in the match we're still in our
first segment so the objective effect of
this game on the course of the match is
probably not as big as I think some
people might make it out to be
especially because I think Karo has
misplayed the subsequent game and I
think Magnus is even angrier now he's
got an even bigger chip on his
shoulder I think he's gotten what he
wanted totally if anyone is you know
wondering yes we did miss the opening
but hey news flash it was the same
opening as every other game so uh that's
a consolation prize here as we are now
up to speed and I wanted to add one last
thing as we see Queen D2 by Carlson
connecting his Rooks setting up the
Potential Threat of Bishop takes H6 he's
got more space better pieces hikaru's
position riddled with Pawn weaknesses
and Bishop takes H6 right now has to be
seriously considered last thing I'm on
when the evalar was showing TB um when
they transitioned to rook and Bishop no
it did not self-diagnose tuberculosis
instead it refers to table basee and
table base refers to all of the
positions with seven pieces are
having been studied so chess is actually
a partially solved game and the
evaluation table base was a draw that's
what it means when the eval bar switches
to
TB that's a good explanation and much
needed because it's like hang on where's
my evaluation where EV especially when
it switches from TB to uh checkmaid in 2
at the very
end okay the elephant in the room
literally the elephant because look he's
going to play it he had time to think
about it Daniel that's the thing he had
four minutes and guess what he's pissed
off from that last game so of course
he's going to do it and the other bishop
and when I say elephant in Russian and
in some other languages Bishop is
elephant so that was the pawn look at
the Exquisite play again using both
sides of the board Bishop B3 does he
have a threat him on uh blundering well
you know uh pin pieces uh I heard they
defend but they actually don't not here
Queen takes G6 after Bishop B3 is the
now elephant in the room and uh Knight
h8 I know he might be trying to uh steal
an idea but uh does not work as well
here Knight F5 threatens Checkmate on G7
and queen f8 you've got the F6 Knight to
pick up and the problem is hearu tries
to stir up some complication I think
that was the only move the only feasible
move is that Black's minor pieces are
dangling and without pawns to protect
them black essentially can't multitask
black can't simultaneously keep his King
protected and keep both of his Knights
under control that's why I would play
Knight takes E5 right now and only after
the Knight leaves G6 would I jump with
the other Knight to F5 that's
essentially a double attack right it's a
double attack on the queen on G7 but
also on F6 and when the queen drops back
to f8 you can simply start picking up
Black's minor pieces none of which are
protected by a pawn none of the four are
protected by a pawn yeah and that's a
really high level calculation there
Knight takes and then an tro Knight F5
but you stumble upon these ideas when
you realize Knight F5 as tempting as it
is Queen f8 meets it so well so you want
to move that knight from G6 or force it
to move the move Pawn takes on E5 Dan is
pretty much achieving the exact same
thing black has to get the Queens off
the board even if it comes at the cost
of a minor piece you might want to just
go Queen f8 and bite the bullet White's
got this sick response Queen H6 to C1
actually hitting the bishop on C6 I will
confess I didn't find that move on my
own but if yaru saves this one with a
minute now on his clock I would be even
more shocked than I was given the
proceedings of the last game and I think
after Knight F5 we might see resignation
very shortly yeah Knight F5 Queen f8 um
talking about forced moves Queen takes
on F6 and maybe he's trying to get
something going with like Knight takes
F3 doubling the pawns Rook E6 Rook G6
swinging over in that direction so I
feel like that might be what hear was
thinking about he knows as well as
Magnus that there's no way this works
out for him but you still have to find
something King H1 just let go of that
Bishop get away from it because king
take the bishop is radioactive right
Knight G4 check is going to pick up
White's Queen and lead to a complete
liquidation it's I love it when you
leave a piece on pre like this and play
King H1 that produces such a nice
aesthetic effect at least for me totally
and and this is a reminder like Bishop
F2 I'll admit I didn't even think of it
because neither did I the moves were so
overwhelming for white that to be honest
it maybe wasn't necessary but that you
know that's a fault of mine I didn't
even see this counter shot hearo is
truly so resourceful but Magnus just
does not need to bite on this bait
Bishop takes F2 here and he can he can
play King takes F2 and When the Smoke
Clears he will be up a a pass Pawn on
Def in fact he'll be up two pawns but we
know how good hikaro is at manufacturing
chances in Lost end games it's the you
know the the quintessential Unstoppable
Force meets IM movable object both of
these players are such Wizards in the
end game that I wouldn't flirt uh with
with even an Iota uh of possibility that
Hikaru builds up some sort of Fortress
Magnus calculating it if he plays King
H1 he virtually ends the game on the
spot yeah but you got to have the
confidence to do that because in some
ways King takes F2 is kind of a stable
Edge you know you have the couple X for
pawns later whereas this you know
there's Knight takes F3 there's Bishop
takes E1 Rook uh E6 to G6 you have to be
sure that you're not actually throwing
the game away by by miscalculating here
so a riskier approach but the correct
one and here's what Magnus had to see
Rook G6 would have run into Knight E7
check with a fork that was critical and
hekaru blocks with the Knight he tries
to keep some Intrigue on the board but I
would just go Rook F1 here I would just
move the Rook away everything is hanging
and hikaro is going to start dropping
minor pieces here what a game what a win
by Carlson to rebound from that shocking
loss in the previous one it's it's
really impressive just from a a mental
standpoint to be able to do that right
to to bounce back from a getting
checkmated rook and Bishop against Rook
he even had two pawns on the board the
outplay from hikaro in the previous game
was insane you know full credit to
hikaro but to just basically silence
everyone it's like by the time we had
appreciated that he had already gone and
won another game and speaking of full
credit we wanted to credit the over
100,000 of you watching this amazing sec
finals match presented by coinbase uh
across the the various platforms you
know when I say that I appreciate people
taking time out of their busy Fridays
these are not just cliche words uh this
is not just boiler plate we truly
appreciate uh the chat and the the
energy that people bring it it lends a
magical quality uh to these events and
these match and it makes them truly
Unforgettable so give yourself a pat on
the back everybody we hope you're
enjoying the match and we've got the
best yet to come we have two more
segments uh the match remains closed
Magnus is up by only up by two and heed
the segment in history that's Caro in a
nutshell it's like 99% accuracy beats
97% accuracy or something I know now
what's going on here Aman you're the
French expert this didn't start out as a
French but it certainly looks like
one uh you see this uh this G5
moov G
maybe we should ask Laur what he thinks
of this
position I think the king side is maybe
a bit open after G4 and Z5 I think drops
here and okay it's
still very
good okay Queen takes C5 what a move
okay now I can't I can't escape the
accent it's like yeah no now it's you're
trapped in it little bit you must
continue okay so are we going to see
Knight B5 by Nakamura to Target the C7
Square these positions I have to say are
so stressful to play with the black
pieces like you you feel like you've
done the absolute best right when when
you read the blueprint for the the the
French let's say cuz it is more like a
French position right now you think okay
get rid of the center right E5 D4 let me
undermine the center that's what the
french is all about well guess what
you've done it and the position is still
extremely unclear as the eval bar points
out that black still has lots to worry
about absolutely but white also has
white has more to worry about than may
meet the eye because once Black's Bishop
from f8 comes out to C5 a on it targets
the F2 pawn and the fact that white
hasn't developed his Queen side might
bite him in the behind pretty
shortly yeah I think I think this is all
about first of all the G Pawn is hanging
so yes you can take it it's not that
easy for black to play Rook G8 um
because you need to Long Castle Lots
needs to happen so the G4 Pawn is up for
grabs but I like Knight B5 however
Bishop C5 is a very aggressive way to
react and it just could become a total
mess okay Bishop B3 instead hikaro
prioritizing his develop
development Magnus could now secure the
G4 Pawn with H7 H5 that of course is the
kind of boiler plate response uh once
you advance the PA to G4 or he could
similarly prioritize his development and
get his dark squ Bishop out which path
is he going to choose H5 feels really
natural and I guess now that Bishop E3
has been played the clear reaction is
Knight B5 there's no Bishop C5 uh to to
think of so Knight B5 I I imagine has to
be um nakamura's idea but you know the
the engine cuz I've looked at these
positions enough the engine will always
be like you know what it's not that bad
for white even if you just develop black
has problems to solve the king is never
fully safe castling King side and
castling Queen side is not that easy to
achieve well you got the square we got
the square right we got the piece wrong
he's put the bishop on B5 an E5 by
Carlson leading to complete pandemonium
in the center but Aman this doesn't
actually threaten I think this is very
important e takes D4 is not a threat
because if Bishop takes D4 Bishop G5 so
Hikaru can take this opportunity to say
you want to open up the center I'll take
it to you A Move Like C4 and Knight C3
would terrify me if I were in magnus's
and that's very much upar alley it
really is but he needs he needs to find
the confidence to play those moves I
think he knows that this position calls
for those types of moves we talk about
the move C4 the move F4 is equally
playable how insane are these moves here
in C4 Hikaru nakima strikes I'm going to
go ahead and give that a brilliant oh
wait it's already done both of these
players have such a keen sense of the
initiative they know exactly when their
opponent starts to lose the thread and
they pounce like a tiger out of the cage
this is also going to be am on the final
game of the 5minute portion so a win by
hikaro would go such a long way toward
reestablishing the momentum that he
seized after that endgame Victory I'm
just go going to go ahead and say it um
Magnus surviving this position will be
so astounding to me because I said it
earlier this position is nothing but
stress for black to play you're you're
getting attacked the whole game C4 is an
incredible move and Karo is feeling the
the Zen of the position he knows the
type of moves that need to happen and
that's frightening so I don't know how
Magnus is going to survive here cor
correct yeah sir I'm just trying to
grasp the Zen the Zen of the position
and speaking are we mellowing out Danel
I remember when Robert hubner uh
practiced Zen meditation at the 1970 uh
hugan chorus vion tournament and this is
getting scarier by the second literally
because Magnus is now down at 2 minutes
why am on I think for for newer play you
look at this position it's chaos on the
board why is this so bad for black I
think it boils down to two things the
first is your permanent lack of King
safety the king is stuck on the E file
it has nowhere to run because the king
side is wide open look at hear Knight C3
and that's the second thing the
superiority of White's piece placement
Black's pieces are stumbling on each
other they're not able to defend crucial
squares let's brilli I'm upgrading it
brilliancy no one one was not enough
there this is the second look at how
many pieces are hanging
oh my gosh I don't think that was enough
exclamation marks him on I just want to
make it clear that when you hang this
many pieces you deserve some credit
Hikaru is head bobbing we know what that
means he's stilling the position and he
is ready to go into the break with a
victory here I I've said it once I'll
say it again I don't think Magnus is
going to survive here it's too tough to
play he's not just head ring he's also
chewing and you know what that means if
you have the mental capacity to go for a
snack during the game that means you're
confident that things are going your way
if black takes the bishop what actually
happens you might be asking white takes
the D5 Pawn with the Knight takes the B5
Pawn with the other Knight and then both
Knights are stering at the C7 square and
you could put this on the board really
quickly as Magnus starts to come to
terms with I would say the hopelessness
of his position we might see this on the
board he will have to allow Knight C7
check give up the rook in the corner and
try to run his King to the king side I
do think that that is the best practical
chance Magnus just Rook B8 look how
calmly he's defending even in the face
of almost certain death that's actually
an excellent move by Carlson he says if
I'm going to die I'm going to die with
an extra minor piece in my stomach and
this game is not over this is not over
and it's it feels insane to even say
that you know at this point white could
consider just like a regularl looking
move like Queen D2 Rook D1 those types
of moves will still build up uh insane
pressure on the position so uh I wonder
if there's something more forcing here
Dan but I might be thinking about just
moving the queen queen D2 also you're
setting up potential ideas like Bishop
E3 to G5 in order to cover the d8 square
but My worry is that Magnus is actually
only a couple of moves away from finding
better shelter for his King he might
play the move F6 and then King F7 and
that King on F7 is going to be a whole
lot safer than it was just a couple of
moves ago yep and it will be on a light
Square which is the one piece that white
is missing in fact a nice move maybe
instead of Queen D2 but same idea is
just to check the king first and then do
it so you force the king to go to that
you know undesirable d8 Square
absolutely and now he Caro down om
minute on the clock I don't think he's
finding anything that he truly likes he
forces the king to d8 but now the king
is very nicely sheltered by the Knight
on D7 Bishop to B6 setting up but what
exactly is the threat I think that's the
problem with this move where are you
actually going to jump with the Knight
A6 I think the bishop B6 move move is
doing my favorite thing threatening to
threaten yeah do threaten it yet but but
it looks scary right I can say that for
sure if you move the Knight you know you
want to run away with the King right now
I think it feels to me like it's time to
move that Bishop so that you have an
escape path great Callum on Bishop to B4
on the board The Rook on you one is also
hanging and again white is down a minor
piece even though it doesn't feel that
way do you make a run for it with King
E7 is now the time and it is and is
Magnus starting to take over the
initiative unbelievable there's no
Bishop C5 check but what about takes
takes Bishop C7 I guess you Retreat the
Knight and want to BL Bishop
D6 Aman Carlson is one move away from
establishing his King on G7 the safest
Square on the chessboard black is now
better I can't believe this and he's
kept his extra piece the entire
time I mean this is incredible uh
defens and he's blundered Rook takes
and Hikaru once again is in charge B5 B5
uhoh oh Bishop D4 was really bad really
bad by
Carlson Magnus lets it slip a little bit
cuz look at the pieces look you're up
material but those pieces aren't in the
game they're not playing so if you're
not using them they're not affecting the
the evaluation of the position there was
absolutely no need for Carlson to give
up his dark squared Bishop now look at
those dark squares along the long
diagonal Queen C3 and Rook E1 and this
feels like a completely different type
of position than just a couple of moves
ago at the same time if Black's Knight
gets to E6 it's very much still a
game Queen G5 okay dangerous looking
move but it covers the things it needs
to cover like the F5 Square the the
queen looking at he blundered on
pan and
H4 wow yeah I was thinking even Queen C5
but th this is even better H4 and the
attack rages for black and now the
bishop can't move because you get M it
on G2 you're going to have oh Tak oh and
Rook takes G3 blundered his Queen Magnus
blundered his Queen he can't cover with
the Knight oh my God this thought he had
Knight G4 but that was nerves exactly he
definitely thought he had Knight G4 now
it's over Knight E8 CH Rook takes D1 and
you can't even tonight and he CaRu
wins unbelievable the I mean I think we
were looking at about a 99% accuracy
match the entire way and this game went
up in Flames now gets the win Dan that
is so needed 5 to four is the score how
many turnarounds did we have at the end
of that game first it was almost a sure
win for hikaro after C4 then Carlson
starts to stabilize he takes over the
advantage gives away his darkr bishop
and then blunder his Queen just when he
was about to deal the final blow the
score is 5 to four and we have gotten
everything that we've asked for him on
and then some wow this was such an
insane finish to the five plus one
portion I mean this it speaks for itself
Dan that the match is within one point I
think we need an instant replay of the
final blunder we don't have the time to
go through every turnaround of that
crazy there was a lot I'm not going to
lie if we could go to move 32 himan
really quickly after F4 Hikaru
forgetting about aant which sets up the
mate threat on G2 he has to waste the
tempo to bring his Bishop back now H4
would have won on the spot because it
would have forced the bishop back and
would to force the queen trade instead
Carlson gives Nakamura a Tempo he uses
his Tempo to bring his Knight back H4
Queen C3 check and now the shocking move
of all F6 here would have kept a winning
Advantage but instead he goes Knight F6
forgetting that white can simply capture
F3 and simultaneously prevent H takes G3
which was played because of Rook takes
G3 picking up the queen now I say
Obviously but with 10 seconds on the
clock in a position this chaotic God
himself wouldn't be able to figure this
out properly
truly I mean what we just saw was uh I
think a great sign for Nakamura he was
not afraid to sack multiple pieces to
take the game to Magnus Carlson yes
Magnus wiggled out of it a little bit
but it was never to the point where it
was done and dusted and you know we were
on to the the next uh format or anything
like that no this game was still up in
the air the entire time and you're going
to be rewarded for being the aggressor
incredible hikaro was the aggressor in
that game magn is Ste the aggressor in
the match he leads by one and we will
let the players take a much-deserved
breather before the next segment but
before we do that we wanted to ask if
you wish that your financial systems
were as fast and as smart as the 2023
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase well they can be check out
coinbase.com updatethe system today or
use xlam coinbase in the chat to learn
more well we have assigned a lot of
exclamation marks to the moves in this
match and we will continue to do so you
are watching the finals of the speed
chest Championship presented by coinbase
more action in just a couple
[Music]
of
I take almost daily I love them honestly
because they taste great I know that
sounds silly but not everyone wakes up
looking forward to taking a supplement
and I legitimately do because they're
tasty obviously they're phenomenal for
you or I wouldn't be taking them a few
years ago I went completely corn-free so
I don't eat anything that has not just
corn but any type of corn syrup which
these days isn't everything and so I
spent a lot of time looking into the
supplements whether it's free workout or
just to like start my day um and I spend
a lot of time looking into that stuff
and there is nothing better than the
ingredients in hey
J1 phenomenal for any type of thing
you're looking you're looking for
whether it's just adding a little more
whatever you want to call it fiber
vitamins all the stuff in them you know
into your diet if you're lacking some of
that if you're legitimately looking for
energy and and ways to kind of start
your day on the healthy side side of the
of the bed if that's a thing or the
chest board but uh no the the
ingredients in this stuff is the highest
quality if you are looking for anything
to boost your diet around it's it's
awesome I also actually take this liquid
stuff which is vitamin D with vitamin K
these days if you're not taking vitamin
K with vitamin D you're basically
wasting your time if you didn't know
that Pro tip you got to have vitamin K
with your vitamin D so anyway I uh I
love AG one whatever reason you might be
looking for
it it just tastes so good like honestly
I have to be careful not to drink too
much because then that can you know can
be too much for your tummy but it's
phenomenal tastes good good for you good
energy makes you feel like you're
starting the day fresh and I recommend
it check out A1 right
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
who he breaks he's going to play A4 oh
my gosh he's got trousers where's the
mate though I don't know but it's got to
be there oh he got God
made oh my gosh oh he's Prim of GF yeah
you have Rook D1 oh oh my God that was
sick oh my God that was nasty Rook
B1 oh my goodness goodbye one bang bang
bang seven wait Bish Bishop yeah Bishop
said rookie 6 is a mate threat oh he's
lost he's position does he have enough
time oh my gosh Magnus has to show off
the mouse speed right now this could be
over if hikaro can bleed another minute
off the magic clock here we go oh oh oh
no he doesn't have enough enough time he
it's over it's over Magnus gives a
little bit clap for hit car
[Music]
Nakamura back we are at the 2023 speed
Chess Championship final presented by
coinbase I almost said 2022 am on we had
that incredible highlight reel there
from last year's finals I've been
experiencing withdrawal for exactly a
year here and I'll be experiencing
withdrawal for another year after this
but we still have a lot of Chess left to
play as Magnus Carlson holds a onepoint
lead let's take a quick look at his 2022
performance up until the loss of Hikaru
Magnus was rampaging through the field
of mine yeah and it kind of reminds me
uh surprise of this year right he has
had a really similar run and you know if
he ends up losing this finals to Hikaru
obviously he's going to be thinking oh
you know he car's done it again that
same type of run from last year so
Magnus is out here looking for his
revenge and guess what Danel we are
approaching that stat that we talked
about earlier the three plus one section
this is his best section against hiar
Nakamura so this is his best place to
cement that Revenge this is where Magnus
has to butter his bread but in order to
do that he's got to set himself up
mentally especially given his last two
losses they weren't consecutive losses
he won a beautiful game there and the
middle but first there was that insane
end game where he gives up his Knight in
a dead drawn position and then that
final game where Magnus somehow climbed
out of a dead loss position only to make
the last blunder so Hikaru he had the
last laugh in the five plus one segment
who will have the first laugh in our
next hour of 3+ one and the gong sounds
again a queen's Indian yet
again yeah interesting I'm trying to I I
guess technically going back to that one
game they did have in it uh it it didn't
really go hikaru's way but I think he
was quick to to realize it didn't have
anything to do with the opening so he
was happy to try this one again but in a
shorter time format now I'm actually
going to be paying close attention Dan
to the time situation early on it's
actually in hikaru's favor but he has
been down on the clock against Magnus a
lot in this match and what just happened
there is I pretty much standard fair
this nichu 594 sequence is common in a
lot of different types of positions can
we rewind we're on the same page yet
again among Knight G5 so what's the idea
of this move it's a double attack Knight
G5 is against the H7 Square which is
mate and Bishop takes B7 so if you take
on G5 you allow Bishop takes B7 and
black actually loses the exchange
because you can't guard The Rook on A8
and save your knight at the same time so
that's why Hikaru covered with his
Knight onto E4 covering the mate
covering the bishop and garnering for
himself a Tempo that he uses in order to
cut the Conta between the two Bishops by
developing the Knight and now the game
uh is much more stable what do you make
of this position that they currently
have yeah that was a great explanation
exactly what the players were thinking
now I think with the Queen's Indian I
always have to just hand that little bit
of an edge to uh to White just based on
the structure like you have more space
more control of the center but this
extended F Pawn is what I'm focusing on
for Hikaru here this is going to give
his pieces some scope on the f file and
if you back that pawn up to F5 and maybe
give white the F4 move then I think the
edge in terms of the Space is really
clear so I like this move that hikaro
has managed to get in I think it's
balanced yeah I mean it's hard to say
whether you know the weight of White's
superiority in the center because if you
just look at the center White's got the
pawns on D4 and C4 White's got the
potential breakthrough with D5 on the
other hand he doesn't have his light
scri Bishop anymore I'm on and he's just
allowed the move F3 girl Magnus calm
down here F3 anybody in going once F3
and queen ag3 and I think everyone is
you know chomping at the bit to
Checkmate Magnus Carlson in that fashion
I mean look he does have ways that he
can prevent this King H1 of course
eventually get a queen uh to F1 Queen D3
Rook G1 but why do you want to have to
defend that position that's what I'm
wondering well I'm wondering that that
too I'm on F3 and it's on the board an
E4 why to prevent Queen F5 but hikaro
says I'm going to fly through a
different airport no direct flight from
Charlotte so I'm going to drive to
Atlanta and and fly to H3 but Queen G4
is met with King H2 and I think magnus's
General philosophy here on is that in
the time that it takes for black to set
up all these threats Magnus is
imperceptibly built a really impressive
Center he's also blundered the move Rook
F4 and I think he's losing the threat of
this game yeah King and by the way H4
while I understand it I actually thought
that H3 was a smarter decision for the
same idea King H2 um after Rook F4 I
think the engine by the way
no come on come
on and now Rook a to f8 I think I think
that the engine doesn't understand how
good this is for black like I think this
is actually one where Hikaru
understands that he's completely winning
and the engine is actually still coming
to that oh my gosh oh my gosh there's an
incredible move here you want to go
takes H4 most people want to do it but
white plays Rook takes F3 and eliminates
the pawn so what you do is you deflect
the queen with Knight takes C4 then you
play Rook takes H4 and there's an
Unstoppable M threat along the H for
example Queen D3 I'm on black just plays
Queen G4 and that's not the end of it
let's say white plays D5 Rook H1 chck
King takes H1 Queen H3 and queen G2 how
sexy would that be and yes I said the
word cuz no other word would accurately
describe this combination truly I mean
this talk about a game after the break
like Magnus just came came out and
played this E3 allowing F3 and now it
feels like he's just getting checkmated
and he's slowly coming to that
realization this is not the way you want
to start to three plus one section and
Hikaru knows that something exists he
has now paused for a minute which is a
long time in a three minute game I think
he's searching searching for that
crushing blow Knight takes C4 is an
incredibly difficult move not only
because it sacks a piece but because it
occurs on the other side of the board
with 30 seconds on the clock hearu
better find it because he might no
longer have the time to manage this
position for a long time he needs to
Checkmate Magnus now and he has found it
unreal and he what a move Knight takes
C4 you explained it perfectly deflecting
the queen all you need is that one
moment that one move after Rook H4 to
play Queen G4 and look technically this
is playable if you take and maybe give
up The Rook but you're you're lost and
Hikaru knows it what a game what a
combination and there's basically only
two players on the planet that can find
a move like this in a Blitz game and
they're sitting in front of us right now
on the camera one is Magnus reminds me
of his Knight takes B4 move against
vidit how the delicious irony right
Knight takes B4 now we shift at one file
to the right hikaro finds Knight takes
C4
is Magnus going to find Knight takes D4
sacking the knight in the next
game yeah we're just going to work our
way
overes Rook takes H4 and it's over Queen
G4 is Unstoppable Queen takes
G3 oh my gosh there's a queen sack on
G oh my goodness that is beautiful the
word sexy we have to use it again Dan
you didn't girl oh
wow just wow nothing but just pure shock
I have to go back to that one Dan
there's there's no way that we can't
show that again and explain what exactly
was going to happen Queen takes G3 of
course a brilliancy look King F1 is not
even a question so you have to take it
but then you unleash the F Pawn moving
down to F1 and Rook H1 and then the mate
King F1 Rook H1 King E2 and look at the
mate F1 queen king D2 Queen C1 shuttling
the queen to E2 and then Queen E1 mate
you have exactly two squares that are
accessible they are the mating squares
this was Exquisite this was a work of
art and you knew that something was
going to go down when Hikaru landed a
Pawn on F3 L's mate he said it on his
stream a million times you knew that he
started to search the moment that pawn
landed on F3 what a game to tie the
match and you think about how you know
that was almost you know not taking
anything away from hiar but very
self-inflicted by Magnus he played E3
and said push your Pawn to to F3 and
Hikaru said uh sure I'll do that and
I'll meet you with a couple brilliancies
is that what you
wanted clearly that's that's what Magnus
asked for and that's what he received it
was unnecessarily provocative and it was
more annoying that for Magnus that he
did it with the white pieces in in a
queen's Indian where he was hoping to
play without risk instead he gets
checkmated I feel like I try as a
commentator Raman now to make less
comments about body language because you
you never know what the players are
actually thinking but man after that
Bish rook and Bishop versus Rook game it
seems to me like Magnus hasn't been the
same yet yeah it's it's so interesting
because he bounced back immediately with
an incredible win to sort of Silence uh
that notion but then you look at the the
games that have followed and yeah I I
couldn't agree more he's not fully
himself and let's give credit where
credits do hear Nakamura has absolutely
you know he's he's joined this match in
a real way he's back in it and the
momentum seems to be in his Corner in
this uh three plus one segment that he's
struggled with in the past and so far
he's also adjusted his clock management
subtly but still in a big way now he's
holding the time advantage in the last
couple of games this game included we
have a really interesting Sicilian where
Magnus has just released the tension
with D4 and C5 the drawback of this
approach is that white now has some
light Square control on the queen side
you can see hikaru's Knight heading over
to C4 the bishop could also Park itself
on A4 uh I think the position is
approximately balanced but I would
probably take white here yeah the the
structure does look pretty pretty
Pleasant here and remember hearon
Nakamura is currently playing for what I
believe would be his first lead of this
match he's t it up and started in the
best possible way now he's got the white
pieces he can keep piling on the
pressure that would be momentous as
would a potential kingside attack that
hikaro would develop if he lifts his
Rook up to F3 or his Queen to G4 Queen
G4 very thematic move here Aman you're
not necessarily trying to Checkmate
black in one Fell Swoop you're trying to
set up the preconditions for a potential
kingside attack I mean Bishop H6 and F4
would come really really fast and that
Bishop which would land on F6
I don't think that's a reliable Bishop
at all I would go Bishop H6 and take my
chances here right because Bishop F6
he's saying okay E5 I've got it covered
but F4 renew that exact threat and if
you play E5 you're opening up this
bishop in general Point yeah that that
looks really scary I'll tell you what
Magnus missed I think Magnus was relying
on King h8 he might play that move and
there might be a pawn that lands on F6
mirroring the narrative in the last game
Hikaru would play E5 anyway and after G
takes H6 e takes F6 Black's kingside is
going to be in shambles and we're going
to get another thematic attack by Hikaru
here Magnus is in trouble yet again I
was going to point out I mean it it
feels like we're stating the obvious but
you have to take a step back and think
that Hikaru Nakamura he's gotten his
wins and actually we've seen Magnus
under the most pressure when he's kind
of just closed his eyes and started
attacking like caveman style he is going
for the king and it's so refreshing and
I think the chat has got to be
entertained by this type of chest Daniel
you don't always see this from you know
the absolute highest levels because
those barbaric kind of attacks don't
work but that is exactly what's working
forar barbaric is a great way to put the
way that this match has preceded Aman
it's not one match it's been two matches
where are the balanced R lopezes gone
are the positional struggles gone are
the long end games gone are the
maneuvering battles now we've got allout
bloody sanguinary action against each
other's Kings except it's really only
against one king Magnus hasn't really
taken too many stabs ataro King recently
mhm and it's on the board you know I you
know Rook G let's let's at least give
some credit to the bishop on B7 who
heard that comment from you and said
well hang on I can make some threats
too you're absolutely right this is uh
you know hikaro is going to bring that
that rook in to E1 maybe Knight E5 F5 is
also on the cards hey the H6 Pawn is
hanging as well and C5 and the C5 Pawn
is hanging and car might absolutely say
listen I don't I'm under no I didn't
sign a contract that I have to win this
game by Checkmate he might take C5 and
then trade Queens on D6 Magnus is also
down to 10 seconds I feel like the
wheels are really coming off in this
game mhm yeah Rook G6 feels like a
normal move to hit the F Pawn guard the
H Pawn but then as you mentioned you
could switch gears and just take on C5
and now you could switch gears and go
Knight E5 which is the square
relinquished by magnus's last move Rook
to E1 would be a great buildup move C3
Bishop C2 so many ideas yeah if you can
bring that Bishop to C2 remember with
5.6 seconds you just need the most you
know complicated procedure for Magnus to
find and that alone might be enough so I
really like to move C3 I think it's
tough to handle and we called it right
he's just taking material and Knight F3
Knight G5 oh no that could be a hammer
blow and he finds it cuz Rook G6 is
impossible The f8 Rook hangs every
detail has been accounted for look at
this this is exquisite called it that's
actually a really key detail and Magnus
was having that precise panic in his
head he like oh Rook G6 an H6 that's
easy but with the Rook hanging Bishop C2
Bishop C2 he doesn't recapture the
bishop and Bishop takes G6 or queen
takes f8 and he wins start this hearo is
on fire he wins with a Miss oh God what
an awful
move that was again he's just taking it
to Magnus Carlson right now this is
honestly amazing to watch I said it
before but I'll say it again you don't
see these kind of like this is not
supposed to be magnus's Kryptonite but
it feels that way at the moment hear
Nakamura is on another level and he's
just any chance he has to attack the
king he's doing it and it's working
right now Magnus needs a game to calm
things down and I like magnus's decision
go back to the R Lopez the Queen's
Indian hasn't been working very well and
what impressed me the most about that
game it wasn't the fast attacking moves
it wasn't the bishop h6s and f4s because
that's pretty standard Fair it was the
slow moves right the Knight f3s and the
C3 Bishop c2s hikaro was able to keep
his composure and find these slow
buildup moves when a lot of people
especially against Magnus would start to
panic and throw all their pieces Into
the Fire hikaro completely disarm
magnus's attempts at counterplay his
time management is improved the good
news for Magnus is that he's only down
by a point we're talking about this like
it's a 10-point match no this is still
very close yeah and this is what we
expected we talked about those win
percentages from these players ear we're
starting to see where it comes from both
of them have taken leads gone on runs
this is speaking of leads hiar acro's
first lead of this SEC final incredible
now what do we make of this latest R
Lopez I again am a little bit biased in
White's favor and the fact that 97
cannot be played here forces Black's
Knight to an awkward Square that's right
and we've seen this opening before from
picaro and I believe this is the game
that featured his uh you know sort of of
uncharacteristic blunder of a full piece
uh last
time indeed and look at that Knight on
B7 it's uh does it have a future I
that's more of a rhetorical question as
you're
indicating not going to answer that with
words I'll just let the arrows do the
talking I would go C6 here honestly with
with Yaro I would try to change the
course of the game also Bishop D3 is a
major threat and the B5 Pawn cannot be
defended yeah and it's a little unusual
ual to feel so comfortable giving away
your dark squ Bishop if you're Magnus
here but it comes with a very well and
you see the move C6 played because the B
Pawn is so weak Bishop D3 he's I think
he's made the right decision Danel
followed your idea C6 it just needed to
happen necessary evil and there's two
main reasons the first is now you can
protect the pawn with Queen B6 the
second reason is how do you harness your
Bishop pair well normally you do it by
opening up the center and that's what
magnus's last move is aimed against
Bishop B3 controlling the D5 Square and
discouraging Hikaru from opening up the
center with D5 we might even see a move
like Queen D3 and the knight from D2
could access the D5 Square through F1
and E3 and that would spell major
positional trouble for Hikaru Nakamura
who still struggles with that Knight
that terrible Knight on B7 and there's
there's a long-term reason why this
Knight is no good right now we can see
its future is pretty bleak but Knight d8
you're thinking okay Knight E6 but white
is going to play the move G3 maybe the
move H4 and you start to see wait every
single forward is covered and again
we're seeing the classic play on all
three sides of the board Queen side
Magnus has the a file Center he's got
the D5 square but was Bishop D5 a little
bit premature because the queen is not
the piece that you want occupying an
outpost you want to take the Knight and
put it on D5 and that's like you know
taking a parking spot that's reserved
for the business that Queen is going to
get towed away pretty shortly but that's
going to cost Magnus a couple of Tempe
and Tempe is money in a position like
this the C3 Pawn could come under Fire
oh the interconnected business money
references Dan is going crazy right now
I like that one Rook A3 guarding the C3
Pawn but multi-purpose as well Rook to
A1 and Rook A6 Rook A7 you're going to
bring the Rooks into the party and again
that Knight is looking for somewhere to
go Knight C6 really doing much and
Knight E6 you will see the move G3 and
you called that when there was still a
piece on d8 so pretty impressive the
Knight finally has a future it's got the
E6 square and Magnus has clearly lost
the Lion Share of his Advantage which is
uncharacteristic these are exactly the
positions where we know Magnus to be
nearly Flawless in Blitz but Bishop D5
was a bit of a panicky reaction I still
think he's got the preferable position
but if hearo gets a knight F4 God forbid
if blacken pushed D5 here the ties could
really turn totally and that's why you
saw Knight E3 he actually wants to play
G3 but I think he realized Knight C7
accomplishes the same thing as Knight F4
and if you can play D5 you might sack
the pawn right and play E4 and that
could be devastating D5 is very much in
the cards it's being threatened and I
think Karu could even play Queen C6 here
targeting the C3 pawn and preparing D5
once more and Magus is going to say Over
My Dead Body he's going to shift the
Rook from E1 to D1 and it's so clear
what the battle is revolving around the
battle is revolving squarely around the
D5 Square oh and you're getting good at
it Daniel
one St longterm thing that we need to be
very careful of if we are playing with
the black pieces here do not let a pair
of Knight's trade and the other Knight
reached the D5 Square that's like you
know worst case scenario and something
went a little bit wrong in the last few
moves by Hikaru because Magnus is very
close to turning that into reality even
if the F3 Knight doesn't manage to reach
D5 I still think this end game requires
a lot more Precision from black than it
does from White and it's almost like
pru's calling card yeah he he heard that
he yeah I've got that I've got that
there's a weird line here because H4 if
the bishop goes back Knight D2 and I
think white is achieving a lot so the
idea are you thinking think Bishop C1
and like what's going on there I don't
like RI takes B5 by Magnus hicaro simply
doubles on the C file he's going to win
the C3 Pawn back and I feel like the
worst is behind him I think he's gonna
hold the draw here with with room to
spare
I agree I agree you can't defend that
pawn the Rooks will invade and if you
don't play Knight takes Bishop then yeah
you may even risk something as well cuz
the rook's going to get behind the pawn
Rook B2 there's going to be going to be
threats there Bish B3 and Bishop B3 is
going to be threatened after black puts
the Rook on the second ring so be
careful if you're
Carlson yeah Rook I guess you could go
Rook C2 but you're running into uh
running into Bishop E3 there instead he
wants to clarify things win the pawn
immediately we've seen Magnus pull out
wins in these types of end games but
given hikaru's current level of
confidence it just doesn't feel the same
way when Magnus had these end games
against Wesley you were almost expecting
something to go wrong now I'm expecting
something to go wrong but from the
opposite side it feels like Magnus is
suddenly worse agreed yep playing so
well but he's got the confidence that's
what really matters he's playing with
that that uh different different level
of intensity right now the position
starting to sharpen up and now it's
liquidating back down finally we see a
piece trade and the C Pawn might get
traded eventually for the B Pawn that's
how these games are often drawn I think
so yeah the king is going to try to move
over to C1 but everyone is just going to
stay put yep o a little bit of tactics
here don't go Rook B6 and blunder Rook
C6 that's the one way to lose this true
and Magnus is going to sign the peace
treaty here in a way am on that was just
as frustrating as the losses because
Magnus got exactly what he wanted with
the white pie and he couldn't
deliver yeah well said and uh Nakamura
is doing what he needs to do when he's a
little bit worse he's fighting well and
he's making those draws but he's taking
his chances his opportunities when he
has them so uh the match has really
turned and I feel like hearo is
following the the perfect match strategy
right now Magnus is suddenly Under
Pressure to get a win because he hasn't
seen one come his way in a while crazy
the way that the momentum turns in these
SEC matches just when you think you have
a handle on who's in charge and who's
calling the shots boom not only did the
results change but the way the moment
the course of the games have changed
completely we have another R Lopez this
time Hikaru playing kind of an old setup
with a Pawn on C4 this was popular I
think in the 8S uh these C4 D3 E4 setups
and I'm going to be honest I don't have
a pretty good handle on anything that's
happening with the bond structor here
yeah it definitely feels like SE takes
needs to happen but you know
light squares for Magnus all I'm seeing
are Easy Pawn breaks for black like
Queen D7 C6 F5 like it feels like
everything is coming for black here and
are we going to see Counterattack is it
time for F5 Magnus needs to strike this
is where Magnus needs to say listen the
momentum isn't going my way but I'm
going to take this one over he has to
play F5 because if he takes on D4 he
allows Knight takes D4 and white
suddenly clamps down on light squares on
both sides of the board C6 F5 Magnus
taking his time
thats us the wheels are turning in his
brain he's definitely cating F5 right
now Y and F5 what is the variation so F5
happens if Pawn takes on E5 Pawn takes
on e4 I want to pull this up on the
analysis board Dan because this is
critical E6 looks really scary I think a
lot of people would see this move and
rule the line out but look at the D5 S
Pawn after Queen I guess Queen E8 was my
idea um Queen C to keep the pawn
protected and Knight D4 that's the
problem it gives up the D Pawn if you go
back to E1 am on instead of Knight D4
you allow Rook to F5 picking off that
pawn and White's position collapses but
Magnus he Engineers a different Pawn
break he's decided to strike on the
other side of the board and this seems
to carry a lot less punch than F5
definitely it it it has a more um I
guess liquidating nature to it um F5 was
definitely playing for the edge but it
was equally you know it was risky as
well uh oh careful w
w and he it he s steps it Queen D6 and
Bishop F6 and he will pick up the D5
Pawn but chicaro could even go Knight C6
and I find it hard to believe that he's
in real danger in that position maybe a
smidge worse because of his pawns but
they're not really accessible to Black's
Bishop that's right yeah and I think we
probably will see something like that
maybe bishop C3 here um I feel like what
hiar wants to do to be perfectly fine is
Play Bishop B C3 and then B4 once that
pawn gets up to B4 I think he knows like
nothing bad's going to happen at that
point and I don't want to keep harping
on the momentum because it's still a
one-point match this could change at the
drop of a hat but I think Magnus early
in the match would have played F5 I feel
like after he jumped out to that
two-point lead he was making decisions
quickly now he's playing with a little
bit more hesitation trying to avoid
getting behind you know by two or three
points but eventually he's going to have
to start taking risks
again yeah I I get the feeling from this
position that Hikaru is very content to
play Bishop here uh at some point play
Knight C6 and I was going to say play
the move B4 and Magnus I think is well
aware that he wants to play B4 so that
Bishop doesn't feel secure on the C3
square and it's a three res game I mean
White's not the only one with weaknesses
on the queen side in fact I would go so
far as to say that black now uh has the
onus is on black to make sure that A6 is
protected Rook B5 I think might be the
only reasonable move here because white
can't take on A6 there because of Bishop
takes C4 with the lateral attack on the
bishop so I'm expecting Rook B5 I'm not
expecting Rook A8 which would lose the
game to Knight B6 and Bishop C7 after
Rook
d8 yep that's a good point um and
certainly Rook A8 just doesn't feel
right anyway you know no um but Rook B5
super strange move to play we talk about
moves that don't feel right uh Rook C8
doesn't feel right although after Knight
B6 I guess there's I was going to say
Rook C5 but there's Knight D7 there he's
going to sack The Exchange after Bishop
C7 I think he's going to pick up the
pawn on B3 take back on d8 with the rook
and this is actually I think a really
high level decision by Magnus Rook to D2
is incoming Bishop F6 and those Bishops
are dominating the Knight on B6 which is
no way back because of Bishop C aming
and this is this is so high level by
Magnus I think it's still equal but this
puts serious pressure on hikaro to play
accurately wow you know just got to uh
you know step aside and let it happen
because that that was sick I did not see
that um at all and this is exactly the
type of shock moves that these players
are capable of because that looked
unplayable I mean you were like this is
lost and I I couldn't see any reason why
not Bishop F6 and suddenly I'm like oh
you were right but for who this is in
the category of Magnus Carlson moves
that I would never play in literally you
can give me a million years to train and
to acquire knowledge about the game and
I don't think I would ever decide upon
an exchange sacrifice out of nowhere in
the end game look at this position why
does a full exchange up he could even
trade the Rooks with Rook A8 he might do
that but the B2 Pawn is so problematic
that Hikaru decides to bail out Rook
takes F6 sacking The Exchange back in a
very heads up decision I think yeah
honestly this is like you know Rook
takes B4 Bishop B5 check King H2 takes
takes Rook uh D2 and we you know it's
just like amazing from both sides the
way they do it
and Rook D4 will defend the B4 Pawn is
anybody playing for a win here nominally
I don't think so Rook to
D2 maybe but I wouldn't give up the B4
Pawn unless you absolutely have to yeah
and there's a weird bit of coordination
like Rook D2 Rook takes B4 Rook takes F2
and sometimes King G1 you know just
shocks you for a minute cuz you're like
I can't take that pawn on
G2 okay Bishop to B five but suddenly
he's given up B4 and whoa he goes for
the three on three with a B Pawn and
this is a draw objectively I would even
go so far as to say this is a handle
black should make the draw handly but
why is he flirting with this yeah I
don't know this is uh this is something
you could definitely lose here the pawn
is going to go up the board it should be
a draw but yeah you mentioned it's just
whoa whoa whoa whoa I feel like Magnus
has improperly arranged his pawns now
King to D4 how do you win these
positions you have to sacrifice the F2
Pawn at some point but you also could
lose this with white if you accidentally
sack your two pawns and black plays G4
he car is thinking about it though and
he's going to buy his he's still
thinking by the way like King F3 is not
like let's make a draw it's I'm I need
more time to process what's going on
here King G4 now don't go King G6 if
you're Carls and he gets his King to H5
but how does he progress from here F4 F4
definitely F4 is going to happen but you
can't get your king out of the cage
without giving up G2 with a check oh
he's allowed King G4 what on Earth did
he just do but wait
now now wait wait a minute so can he
actually win this Pawn that's the
question the king comes in he's going to
put the pawn up to H6 he can win the F
Pawn maybe but after H6 remember the
king is going to hide out on H7 there
has to be a winning plan here but can
hekaru find it with under 10 seconds on
his clock okay mag moves are easy Rook
B1 Rook B4 you give the lateral checks
as long as you can White's King will
approach the rook and that's when you
play Rook B1 King E6 and black is in
Zang King F5 he wins King F7 same thing
no way how on Earth did he take that
game I have those were some of the most
bobbest headed movements I've ever seen
from Hikaru Nakamura and just you know
let's give him space to Bob accordingly
because he should after that performance
he just won that position he's winning
games against Magnus Carlson that you'd
never expect anyone should be able to do
you saw this game and you could put a
silver dollar on the fact that Magnus
Magnus is the one from whom we're used
to seeing these endgame victories out of
nowhere it's a three on three Aman and
we already have seen this we saw it in
the game where Carlson hung a night here
he didn't hang a night he actually got
out played first he gave up the B Pawn
he made a concession and thought that
Brook End Game was easy to save and
somehow you know the the the path to a
draw as my coach used to say when it
gets narrower and narrower and narrower
like that eventually you're just not
used to having to find a single forced
move Magnus is reeling right now and he
is down by two points he's reeling and
he's making decisions which I would say
are uncharacteristic you know normally
such a practical player why did he want
a position where seemingly like he could
only play to lose it right that the
material was even then he gave up a pawn
to play a rook end game where it's like
you your best result is a draw so why go
down that path only bad things can
happen and bad things did happen and
they did and Magnus needs to stem the
bleeding this is a huge game because
this is the game before our halftime
break uh of the three-minute portion
Magnus deciding to go into the Berlin
endgame and a very thematic Pawn
sacrifice pushing E6 damaging Black's
pawns even further and now he's going to
get his knife and fork ready and try to
win that E6 Pawn back that's right and
you know we're going to have that
classic situation where whites trying to
get a mobile Pawn majority three against
two whereas you know Black's Pawn
majority is not I wouldn't use the word
mobile because the pawns are doubled and
you can't create a pass Pawn easily
125,000 of you across twitch and YouTube
watching I see car Nakamura seizes the
momentum and the two-point lead for the
first time in this match what incredible
turnaround although I like the way that
Magnus is handling the end game when
you're reeling that like that Aman when
you're struggling it doesn't matter if
you're Magnus or you're Joe Schmo you
want to do the same thing you want to
steer the subsequent games in the
direction that you feel most comfortable
you want to go back to your roots and
for Magnus that means getting into end
games in which he feels
comfortable so I was I mean going to ask
the obvious but did did he hang the C6
Pawn did did he realize it was hanging
or is there yeah what's going on here no
Rook Rook takes C6 and The Rook
evacuates VI C4 even if black plays
Bishop D6 it doesn't trap The Rook yeah
did they both miss a free Pawn it's
almost like Mutual blindness uh they're
seeing all the same things and they're
missing all the same things that's
really weird it was literally up rook
takes C6 simple as that now Hikaru puts
his King on B7 I still think he's worse
I think he's struggling get his pieces
out largely because of the H6 Pawn himon
because you can't go Bishop
G7 that's right and there still is a 3v2
brewing which is why you know Black's
not necessarily in a rush to take and
trade because I don't I don't know like
what what's the next procedure after
that H hard to develop hard to develop
Magnus he really really needs this win
this is the kind of position we're used
to seeing him convert and he's gotten
the dream Berlin setup he has the three
on two King side and more active pieces
yep no this is uh I would say one of the
most important games of the match I mean
hikaro pulling off a draw here is going
to feel like a win totally and Carlson
trying to prevent that from happening
pushing H4 trying to introduce more
attackable weaknesses on the king side
yeah it's I mean I don't think that's a
mistake at all really it looks like a
pretty good move to me King H3 and
Knight H4 of course he wasn't going to
blunder the G Pawn with takes H4 there
well they blunder the C6 but never say
never man that's good point back you
blundered pong that
Governor where you don't
say Okay GH Rook G5 hear trying to go
after the gpon but Knight G6 might
defend the pawn tactically Knight G6
Rook takes H5 check King G4 and you've
got two pieces hanging at the same time
easy pickings for Magnus Carlson who's
going to FY his Knight back to F4 we
just talked about blundering a pawn and
it's like Oh you mean like
this now am on Knight F4 it's so
important to understand that Rook takes
C5 and Bishop takes F4 is losing for
black because the minor pieces are
incapable of handling the H Pawn mhm
yeah but that is a really it's like such
a strange concept cuz you always always
in chest and two pieces for The Rook of
course it's better of the two pieces but
the minor pieces are notoriously very
very poor at defending not only against
pass pawns but especially ones on the
side of the board A and H pawns and
that's exactly what white has I would
also be tempted by the move F4 trying to
give up the H Pawn in order to shuttle
the F Pawn off the board quickly but if
you can play Knight F4 and you get away
with it you absolutely should Knight F4
Rook F5 there's King G4 White's pieces
are ideally positioned to support those
minor pieces but Magnus that lack of
confidence is it going to bite him yet
again he's now down on the clock he has
to find KN F4 that is a really really
important move yeah and it should be
said that F4 is like a very decent
backup and this is a complicated move to
play Knight F4 invites everything
because you might think oh the king is
coming and if my H Pawn is not going as
fast as I think it should it's not
something that you can be to confident
in go I'm on 15 seconds he's played the
bishop to F4 he puts a third piece on
that square and Rook F5 ATT in the
bishop in order to go after White's
Queen side pawns what an incredible
decision and Rook G5 Hikaru is
navigating these tactics with
unbelievable Precision yeah Bishop takes
H6 it was just Rook takes F2 I believe
and pawns falling and without any pawns
left you're not going to win Magnus has
to be careful here I know it sounds
crazy but I would be playing this for a
win given the time situation if I'm
hearo he's bobbing his head Rook takes
f24 it's just bar surviving
Magnus is going to lose the B Pawn and
he has another end game to defend I I
can't believe we're saying this and he
let his clock run too low
mhm oh my go yeah Rook E3 is such a
stable move so Rook F3 you have to I
would I mean Rook D3 Now isn't that just
a draw it was now he's gone Rook B2
allowing Knight E7 the Knight going back
where is it going back to D5 Bishop f8
has to be considered but don't get
yourself checkmated if you're Hikaru
Rook D7 check and Knight C6 up a mate
threat and that's why he goes to F4 and
back to A8 and Bishop B8 whoa that's why
he does
this oh my gosh he's playing for a
win yeah this is very very strange he's
playing for a win magnus's Knight is
stuck and black has connected passers
him on this Magnus is the one that needs
to be careful though yeah yeah for sure
King B7 and there's no Knight D7 oh no
oh no oh no oh no there's only one move
in that position and nobody could
produce it no absolutely
insane I can't believe it Magnus is like
how did this just happen this was the
most unbelievable endgame yet have you
ever seen a mic drop in chess this was
one of them this was an actual mic drop
moment Hikaru has left Magnus at the
board he gets up emphatically and I mean
he should be walking like a champ right
now I can't believe
that he's won backto back to back games
that it looked like had no business that
was literal Wizardry and I wanted to
point out him the last moment where
Magnus actually made the losing move was
here and we already knew that things had
gone completely Haywire the Knight was
stuck such an instructive moment for
newer players you see how strong much
stronger the pawns are than the Knight
the only drawing move was and I'll let
you show it him on sorry Rook H6 Rook H6
instead of Rook H3 sorry Rook H6 and
Rook H6 like you know to play this move
would would be like actual sorcery what
is this the point is King takes B8 Rook
takes B6 and then Rook B4 rounds up the
pawns but the second point the one
that's harder to see is that if instead
of King takes B8 black plays C3 you
actually use the Knight on B8 as a
springboard and stop the pawn from C6
but that at this point was impossible to
find Magnus let his clock run too low
and he gave up that H Pawn and that's
when sense the game starting to turn yep
and to for this to be the basis of that
position being equal it's like no you
have to go back and revise your
valuation no hikaro was playing that for
a win and this was it practically it
might have just been lost right because
totally you can't you can't base the the
uh evaluation of oh yeah it was equal
and you know Magnus just blundered no if
he has to find this those were insanely
good practical winning chances from
hikaro and he knew that going into it
and if Magnus can't convert this
position if Magnus can't do what he does
best what he's hung his hat on for his
entire chess career and he's in huge
trouble in this match and he's in
trouble objectively losing the
three-minute portion four and a half
half and he really really needs this
break but before we go on break we
wanted to remind you not to miss out on
what month is it not September it's
September through the end of this month
claim up to 30% off on all new Subs on
Twitch subscribers gain access to
exclusive Breaktime content during
broadcasts unlock new emotes and score
an adree experience on chess.com don't
miss out on the deals this subtember
subscribe now okay well we will let this
September continue with an incredible
SEC finals presented by coinbase hicaro
holds a three-point lead Magnus has
coming back to do he has some mental
work to do and we will be back with the
second portion of the 3-minute segment
in just a couple of
minutes
[Music]
God it's the same thing every time why
didn't you on basant bro I swear to God
aant should be forced all my friends
watching and this is taking forever play
faster if I could move this Pawn
backwards it would basically be
Checkmate and draws are dumb I should be
able to flag him no matter how many
times I repeat moves 1,400 years and
it's the same game every time you know
what it's time for some updates I'm
tired of this I'm I'm doing it stalemate
is now a win for the player who gets
stalemated you're welcome Eric Rosen hey
it's the Rosen trap pawns can move
backwards why is that never not been a
rule PS can move backwards now every
piece should be allowed to on sa what
that's not even possible how ship it
dunzo update enter why is an ending
there's just two kings on the board what
is this Purgatory this is so awesome
what we're doing here guys we're
changing chess why can't people just
move however they want whenever they
want wait what check me do I not get to
move from now on C4 actually explodes
pawns are weak no more pawns can promote
on the first move update take that R I'm
not sure I made the users as happy as I
thought I would maybe chess doesn't need
an update Financial systems do need an
update though coinbase is working on
just that reenvisioning an entirely new
Financial system that is decentralized
and fully transparent thank you coinbase
for sponsoring competitive chess and
making events like the speed Chess
Championship possible go to coinbase.com
updatethe system today to learn
more what's the best way to follow any
chess event from the Champions chess
tour to the candidates speed chess
championship title Tuesday Fay world
championship and so much more chess.com
events has all of the top chess
tournaments played both over theboard
and online analyze and review games from
the world's greatest player with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more even
compete by voting for your predicted
results explor chess.com events today on
web or with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never
before
[Music]
[Applause]
absolute Insanity has broken out at the
speed Chess Championship Finals
presented by coinbase as seear Nakamura
has jumped out to a three-point lead
halfway through the 3 plus one segment
but it's how he's done it on the
strength of some unbelievable turnaround
victories and he leads the 3-minute
segment 4 and a half half There's the
Man himself Hikaru has been nothing
short of incredible this year thus far
in the match and of course the previous
5 years hikaro has instituted his
hegemony over online chess and he's done
it through one finals win after another
here's what was the case when hear I
like this the champion I'm on which one
is the crazy
to well you're going to have to explain
what's a what's a galone uh we don't we
don't have that up here a gal wait
listen on in South Carolina gas was
under $2 back when hiar nikim were
rewards an SEC Champion
unbelievable remembers it's just a
Mainstay you know like death taxes and
hikaro being the SEC Champion truly and
if he continues that I mean he's going
to be taking down Magnus Carlson which
he's looked poised to do thus far but I
mean it's Magnus Carlson he's never
going to go quietly you feel I've never
Magnus has never lost like a blowout
match so you have to feel that if if
yaru keeps this pressure up and keeps
getting these wins we're in for a result
that we've simply never heard of from
Magnus Carlson well first and foremost
Magnus has to he has to win a game he
has to prove to himself that he can win
a game in the three minute time control
and this has made all the more
incredible by the fact that Carlson has
not lost to date a 3+1 segment against
iaro and this is very likely to be the
first but let's see if he can reduce the
deficit going into the bullet 22 minutes
left and we have an opening that we
haven't had before the Rosal limo which
featured very prominently uh in several
SEC matches thus
far and I mean I guess more important
than the change of opening is the change
of attire here for uh Magnus is this uh
you think this is uh you know oh that
shirt was attributed to a bunch of
losses this shirt Fresh Start let's see
uh if this can shake up the
moment hey you got to do what you got to
do chess players are pretty
superstitious maybe he he's gotten
sweaty and I wouldn't blame him I mean
you you just get sweaty by definition
when you're facing an on form Hikaru
nakura what's going on in this position
the center is open black and stick a
rook on d8 and that seems like a kind of
lwh hanging fruit type of move white now
has to decide on a accommodations for
the queen and I don't see a square that
I particularly like here for white yeah
I think Rook d8 is one of those moves
that of course you expect like you know
your opponent's going to chase your
queen but still when the moment arrives
you're like man like really have to move
this thing as you mentioned Queen C2
might run into Bishop H3 Bishop F5
there's a lot of tactics which is why
Knight D2 was played to support that
Knight Here Comes Knight B4 great
response by Magnus and I think an
encouraging response by Magus showing
that he's still confident in his ability
to handle complex tactical situations
the D3 square and the C2 Square those
are the main problems for white I would
consider Queen to B3 hikaro with Bishop
to D4 and immediately Magnus sacrifices
the bishop on H3 change of shirt change
of Play Change of attitude for Magnus
Carlson what do we make of this I was
actually going to say change of shirt
but the same guy underneath remember he
hit Bishop takes H6 in a previous game
and this feels reminiscent to that
because I'm looking at how you defend
against this and well the usual uh
suspects are Knight H2 right to cover
the the gForce s but hang on you can't
play that move the other idea is to get
something to F1 C5 and Bishop F1 or
queen E2 Queen F1 those are the ideas
but it's not that easy to achieve
there's Knight C2 in the position
there's a rook takes D4 after Knight G4
idea there's so many things that can go
wrong and he is in his instincts guess
what he does not have absolutely
everything calculated Dan but he knows
that this is the you know things are set
up perfectly for this type of sacrifice
and it's not even such a high-risk move
he's gotten two pawns for it right this
is very different from sacking a queen
or sacking a rook you don't necessarily
have to prove anything right now you can
just kind of chill Hikaru certainly
can't chill he's under a minute and this
isn't even the first time Aman that
Magnus has sacrificed a bishop on H3
remember in that R Lopez game that
rebound game in the five-minute portion
feels like eons go he sacked on H6 and
he did it very similarly he followed his
intuition and magnus's intuition in
these types of situations are second is
second to none Hikaru doesn't have a lot
of seconds left to figure out a
defensive
strategy can he pull out another
miracle he doesn't want his seconds to
turn to none if he wants a chance in
this game Bishop to E5 he's trying to
bring reinforcements in but I mean
there's so many things wrong with the
the current position Knight D3 Knight G4
I mean your pick at a good looking move
here Knight D3 excellent move good
Callum on Knight H5 going after
harassing that Bishop but also preparing
to get the Knight to F4 that's a very
Magnus likee move I've played him enough
in bullet to know that Magnus loves
these Cy unexpected moves and right on Q
amazing yeah at this point I mean Knight
G3 is as much of a threat as Knight F4
so I mean it just looks like you don't
have any options here
what comes to mind this looks so
frustrating yeah Knight G5 kicking the
queen away queen says I'm more than
happy to sink my teeth into F5 also the
other side of the board don't ignore
that Bishop on B5 which can be targeted
with A6 that's also a very Magnus likee
move he likes to use both sides of the
board just when you think he's going to
attack on the king side he throws you in
for a loop and goes after the other side
of the board I'm almost expecting A6 he
could also go Queen H3 and take a and go
bobbing for apples again yeah that's a
really good point because there is going
to be just a a knight B2 move to follow
up so I love A6 Force Bishop A4 and then
instead of taking the Rook you can
actually take the pawn on B2 take the
bishop and then grab the rook in the
corner and you're kind of like picking
apart the white position as you
mentioned on both sides of the board I
mean the king is going to be left to to
hang out to dry at the end of that line
yeah because White's Queen is going to
be on A4 presumably it's going to
recapture the Knight so that move Queen
H3 Magnus is keeping it in his pocket
and awaiting the perfect opportunity to
go back after oh and queen E5 is even
stronger Now The Rook is hanging F5 is
threatened the wheels are coming off
completely the knights are woefully
incapable of Defending all the
weaknesses F5 resigns and Rook
takes how about that am on Rook takes D2
and queen E1 after F5 beautiful
beautiful the wheels are coming off as
you mentioned G3 is going to be hanging
Rook D2 tactic Magnus has started this
portion emphatically
not only did you need a win but you
needed a win precisely in the style I'm
pretty stunned that he didn't find uh
Rook takes D2 he has a little bit of
work to do here and after seeing the
previous few games uh Aman can you blame
me for you know still being a little bit
on edge yeah four connected pass I think
Magnus needs five you know maybe even
six to just to be safe you know Knights
are tricky pieces but 4.9 seconds and a
dream is all hear has here he's going to
play Knight D5 he's going to you know
box out that that Rook to claim a
basketball term here and King G7 and
push the H Pawn I think you want a pawn
as far as possible from those Knights
you want to go G5 H5 H4 just
indiscriminately start pushing your
pawns because White's Knights are are
stuck in place if you move the D5 Knight
away you lose the other one the other
Knight on E5 had no squares there's
nothing left to play for and the way
that he won that game is so encouraging
for Magnus fans he went back to what he
does best playing intuitively putting
pressure on all sides of the board and
on the clock mhm yep and he's back to a
position that he's had success with so
I'm sure that he'll be happy to be here
but obviously if hearo is repeating he's
probably checked this position out I
think if I'm thinking back to the the
beginning of this 3 plus1 section did we
not have that insanely nice attacking
game by Hikaru and it was like what a
way to start remember Pawn F3 I think
that was the first game and now game
after the break it's Magnus who comes
back and says okay I'm a different
person here I got a new shirt on don't
forget and it's hard for me to even say
this but 45 minutes into the start of
this 60-minute segment comes magnus's
first win I mean not only do we not say
that every day we've never said that I
mean we expect all we don't say that all
we might never even say it again so you
know Tak in this match while it's going
I don't love the kinds of positions that
Hikaru has gotten out of the opening
which is also a weird thing to say
because it's an end game but it's also
an opening can Magnus open up the king
side with G4 and F5 can he create
connected
passers I think that Magnus is playing
with the the kind of energy right now
that that's exactly what he's going to
do uh there's one defensive idea it
crazy call it a defensive idea but if
you didn't play the move G4 black would
actually play H5 themselves and stop the
move G4 which would stop the move F5
which would halt the E5 Pawn so it
doesn't look like much but H5 I consider
be a real threat there and if you play
it now you're not in time to stop F5
Rook F1 Magnus is not going to miss this
chance to push no and E6 here he can
push now the other Pawn forcing the
Knight away and then play F5 now what is
hearo banking on he's banking on a dark
Square blockade on F6 the issue is that
he can hold these pawns down for a while
but eventually when White's Knight joins
in the action through G4 which I think
is a square that will be opened up after
the trade it's only a matter of time to
me until Carlson can set his Pawns in
motion once again
that's right and remember there's no
pass Pawn coming from this four on three
over here so it's basically two
connected pass pawns a rook that can't
join the fry and yeah you mentioned it
we might just see a bunch of pieces
trade and although we won't see the
pawns crash through and make a queen
immediately long term I mean White's
just going to bring the king up to the
center H5 I think has to be tried to
prevent Knight G4 at all costs you have
to prevent F6 but now Carlson will
switch to a slow burn approach and this
exact thing this Slow Burn technical
conversion is what we are used to seeing
him do flawlessly he's also struggled
with it mightily in this portion so this
is a big game also from a confidence
perspective can Magnus convince himself
that yeah I'm still Magnus Carlson and I
still win these types of games smoothly
or will hearo pull out yet another crazy
comeback in the end game yeah I was
thinking Rook H4 is kind of a it's
almost like he baited that like Rook F4
and now Rook here and you know as
tempting as Rook h8 Knight G4 is I think
it's smart to play King H1 first maybe
cuz I'm worried about Rook G8 but Knight
G4 is such a beautiful you know
geometric move pins Galore and King H1
Aman is also a great move because you're
preparing Rook G1 and Rook G7 so hikaro
I think trying to defend from the G5
square but the moment The Rook is kicked
away from the G file that Rook on F1 is
going to find Green Pastures to continue
a uh a sub theme of today's commentary
on G7 which is a green
square that's right Rook G5 and that you
can't quite Kick The Rook out it's like
a little bit annoying yes you can play
Bishop C1 but then you remove the
possibility of Bishop takes Knight and
Rook H5 you can play Rook G1 but that
drop that pawn and then Knight F3 but
you drop F5 so it's not that easy and
Rook hf4 preparing to involve the Knight
he rolls out the red carpet you know the
airplane has arrived and where is that
Knight going from F3 well that's the big
question G6 comes to mind because if you
can kick away the bishop on E7 then you
remove the wrong Jenga block and the
whole Tower comes crashing down which I
think is going to happen I would have
played Knight H4 though he's allowed
Bishop D6 and I think that's a small
imprecision giving Hikaru a little bit
more latitude on the king side but look
at this Knight G6 anyway and knight7
Knight G8 wins I guess you have kn7 he
might have even just planned this to go
Rook takes F4 which might be good enough
but this is even better this is the
Magnus that we know he didn't just win
this he won this with a lot of room to
spare now he can take either minor piece
I would take on because the Knight is
much worse than the bishop at stopping
these passers totally and after you take
here you have the perfect setup your
pawns are on light squares and your
Bishop controls the opposite color
complex on the dark squares so you can
play F6 F7 and the pawns cannot be
stopped he could have flirted with the
immediate F6 but what is the point of
that you can just move your Rook back
you can play C4 you can play F6 this one
is a couple of moves away from its
conclusion hikaro might resign right
here there's just nothing left with
which to stop these passers he he wants
you know F7 Rook takes E6 f8 In Your
Wildest Dreams exactly oh not GNA happen
will we see a rook sack on G8 followed
by F7 like Knight f8 E7 Knight E6 and
Rook G8 forces The Rook away from E8
that's what we're missing that's the
cherry on top and I think we're going to
see it I think the gods are going to
grant us a rook sack at the
end no well there was it was impossible
because of Knight takes F6 actually
I think Knight takes F6 and well I was
actually starting to think of uh you
know the the gamesmanship in Hikaru
because why else would he be playing
this on right he's already playing the
clock and with 10 minutes left in the
three-minute portion I think you're at
that threshold where every minute starts
to become important and I actually think
hiar wants to get into the bullet
ASAP yeah I'm just going to point out
here uh Bishop takes C5 a terrible
terrible mistake Rook takes C5 keep the
King cut off Magnus you got to preserve
the seconds here what are we talking
about maybe avoid stalemating with a
queen
A7 Queen E8 mate is coming up and hikaro
has gotten to the point where he is
checkmated in two moves he can still go
King F1 um so he does have a safe move
and he's going to take a solid 90
seconds off the match clock with uh uh
with with this gamesmanship as you
called it and and look say what you want
about it but this is the precise
thing that got Hikaru the win last time
mhm right so I mean and it was so
literally the fact that he had done this
earlier in the match that you know later
on in the bullet segment when it came
down to one win it was like two seconds
remember two seconds that he had taken
off the clock earlier and that's why he
won and I'm going to be dead honest with
you man this is what I truly think
hikaro in the past he's had some
questionable antics you know he
sometimes gets emo after losses but this
milking the clock when you're up on the
match and you want to get to your best
segment as quickly as possible is a
completely legitimate strategy he's
maximizing his chances of Victory and
what do we truly want from the the
players in this match you know do we
want some imaginary concept of chivalry
or do we want the players to maximize
their chances of success I think it's
still the
latter yep yep and and you know everyone
is well within their right to to do that
you know it's not it's not something
that's just reserved for him um but I
think because he's so talented in the
bullet segment that we see him maybe
more than others uh do it and it it's
just because of his prowess there and
it's easy to say I don't know what I'll
be doing with those 30 seconds that
we're waiting for hikaro to let us clock
run out but I think we're all going to
survive and will Magnus survive another
Sicilian hikaro going for a slightly
weird line I don't like the bishop on C4
it's just kind of biting on Granite so I
would consider dropping it back to D3
and maybe opening up the diagonal with
E5 of course Magnus could beat him to
the punch with D6 but not right now
because he would drop your dark squ
Bishop to
B4 yeah and I think that's exactly why I
like the move C3 because I want to play
Bishop D3 but no need to drop the bishop
pair or hand it over so C3 and now you
can bring the bishop back but more
trades introduced by Magnus here it does
feel very equal indeed and the Knights
are going to get swapped here
Bishop F4 possible but instead he car
trades immediately just a kind of I mean
given that this came from a sicilian
this is very
vanilla it is um there there's also this
A6 pawn it feels like nothing right now
but it's actually very annoying for
Magnus like you can't just play Rook d8
go D5 or something you will need to
probably play the move A5 at some point
um which you know it's not the worst
move but it's a move that he has to
spend indeed and how is Saro going to
arrange his pieces I mentioned Bishop D3
earlier he plays it now and the Big
Moment of Truth will we see D5 or will
we see a slower approach like A5 and D6
I think it's in magnus' style to push D5
he's shown a willingness to change the
structure uh and create tension
especially in the last couple of games
where we see the more confident Magnus
that made an appearance at the start of
the match I think we're going to see D5
and likely a bunch of trades in the
center yeah and it's important to
remember that the pawn on F2 is stuck
you can't just respond with you know F4
E5 and close things up the only way to
get that to happen well you know pin
pongs they can't move ah that rule it
was introduced I was there I was aware
drinking some lemonade all right go
ahead last time that Hikaru Nakamura was
not the SEC Champion puns could play to
F4 here I remember that time too and D5
is on the board after a sizable think
will we see a bunch of trades on e4
another end game yes sir why the heck
not I definitely see why hearu wants to
play this I mean if you're Magnus you're
not going to shy away from something
like this you know you're not
significantly worse but I do think that
the Queens side majority if there's just
the slightest of advantages or
preferences I would take white because
of that I totally agree am I like to
point out in such situations that the
side with the smaller Pawn majority has
an easier time creating the past Pawn
when I say smaller I don't mean smaller
like you have less of a pawn Pawn
majority smaller numerically it's a 3 on
two versus a four on three on the king
side and if it's a 2on one then it's
really easy to create a passer if it's a
two on three all you have to do is play
B4 C4 and C5 whereas for black the
distance between these actual pawns is a
lot wider but all of this is a moot
point as long as you have a bunch of
pieces on the board because it's really
really hard for white in practice to
actually set his Pawns in motion without
creating
weaknesses that's right and you know I
think the king placement also
contributes to why I feel uh like like
he car's position is um pretty nice here
and so Magnus is looking to equalize
that and immediately get the king into
the middle of the board it just it's one
of those things that needs to happen
AAP and we have Rook to C4 threatening
is saru threatening anything am on I'm
having a hard time uh perceiving you
know if there's any threat with this
move yeah well whether or not there was
and we'll never know the move B5 has
been played to kick the Rook out yeah B5
was played
B44 and will B4 be played before
B4 I think B4 will be played before B4
because B5 could go to before before
before and before we say anything
further we need to cover the moves
actually played in the game Bishop B3 by
hikaro and guess what he's done he has
reduced the size of his Pawn majority
again to a 2on one now all he needs to
do is play B3 and C4 so maybe we'll get
C4 before B4
I I hope so because I have the perfect
emote to drop on that square Dan let me
tell so and hikaro has the perfect piece
to drop on A7 that would be a rook and
he is making moves
here yeah Bish drops back to E3 and King
D3 this is actually the pawn structure
you don't want to see as black whoa whoa
whoa whoa E4 before before before and we
will get C takes before Rook C2 check
that's what he's banking on but King D3
and King C3 I think was overlooked by
Carlson oh and King C2 we have to show
this line CB amazing Rook C2 this is
crucial King D3 Rook takes B2 King C3
now it's obvious you can't take on B4
but Rook B1 seems to keep the tension as
you're showing him on uh this line but
Rook B1 King C2 was overlooked by Magnus
and you're in huge trouble because of
this tactic and the bishop picks off The
Rook before
before
that is amazing and King D3 a Miss of
course a Miss why I guess because if you
had gone to D1 you could have gone to C1
and maybe that's marginally better I
still think King C3 and King C2 is a
great winning chance he's missed
it wow and I think what that line
actually was was that King to C1
actually trapped the rook and forced him
to take whoa that was a big moment but
Magnus still has to be a little bit
careful here White's got the more active
rook and the better practical chances
mhm King E4 but okay some chances yeah
get the king to Center by the way we've
seen 0.00 we've seen you know Magnus be
in these Rook end games and guess what
Hikaru Nakamura is the guy who can turn
these into wins so just be careful if
your Magnus because you have to just
admit you have lost these
before pretty scary and now you've got
to take with a PA if you take with a
rook white gets trousers I think most
people in the chat will know that term
now said it many times a Russian Chester
referring to two past pawns on either
side of the board that can't be stopped
and G3 is super precise chess he's going
to use his G Pawn as a counterweight to
prevent whites Pawn from reaching H7
fast
enough yeah and you'll definitely see
King E4 here trying to get it but even
if the black pawns were not on the board
it would be a draw so actually it's the
presence of the pawns that maybe gives
you shaky feet here man I I think the
Eva bars developing a disturbing cough
might it have tuberculosis oh I think
it's it's TB early on set well it's TBD
whether it has TB but the TB is
indicating a draw and hikaro I think he
sensed that he had a chance there big
big game and an even bigger game to
conclude the three-minute portion am on
the bullet is going to be one of the
most epic match segments I think we ever
going to see it really will and you know
there's obviously it could be said about
any match you know there's a difference
between going in with the score tied or
one player has the lead but between
these two guys where you know there's
never really been uh that much of a
difference between them that one point
that one game a half a point makes all
the difference so yeah you could talk
about momentum but strictly based on the
score and how narrowly close these
matches have been yeah this game's
important you're totally right and this
is giving me shades of the Nakamura mvl
match where Hikaru was down by two going
to the final game of this portion and he
managed to win it and that really really
set the toneo obviously he dominated all
across the bullet but but if Magnus
could tie the matcher man would that go
a long way toward filling him with a lot
of momentum and right now this is
resembling last year's match where the
score going to the bullet I think was
something like a one or two-point lead
only for Hikaru we have a transformation
here in the R Lopez hearo has put his
Knight on E7 as opposed to F6 uh as has
been standard in their games thus
far yeah and also the trade on E5 I I
think the position last time we saw this
featured you know some rather strange
like Knight A5 uh B5 sorts of positions
Instead This one is much more calm all
around and I think Magnus is probably
happy here with a stable position that
he knows he could not be worse in
especially as the final game in this
segment it feels like a position where
if you want to draw to go to the bullet
uh you know nakamuro would certainly
acques so uh you know magnus's game to
to play it looks like for sure and hi
Caro has to decide on which side of the
the board he's going to operate B5 is a
tempting move but you're also
introducing long-term weaknesses on the
queen side as we know white will have
the typical A2 A4 strike you can go on
the other side and I think the move huk
car is turning over in his head is
actually G5 potentially even followed by
F5 but that also allows Avenues to be
opened up such as the queen dropping
back to B3 with a check I'm definitely
surprised at the move C6 that is ultra
committal and Ultra risky because look
at the D6 Pawn totally yeah th this
immediately makes me think of like the
direct approach Rook D1 uh the pawn is
loose and pinned so the queen has the
Sid step but you know it introduces
options for white to play Queen B4
Bishop G3 E5 with the right amount of
pressure on the E7 Square this can turn
very dangerous and some really basic
moves that Magnus needs to play right
these aren't like you know out of these
world moves it's like Rook 81 let's go
and I'm surprised he's not playing them
he's taking a large chunk of his time
here obviously he's figuring out the
right way to arrange his pieces but I
could just start with Rook D1 and Bishop
G3 and then think he's played it he's
got so many easy ways to increase the
pressure on the pawn bishop G3 Queen B4
double Rooks on the defile he could do
all three of those successively instead
he expands first on the king side that's
such a typical Magnus move again playing
on both sides of the board it's been a
theme of this match it's a theme
featuring in all high level matches and
games yeah and this actually not only
maybe has the Ed of H5 in the future but
it really restricts black from that G5
idea G5 F5 no longer exists there's no
G5 Knight G6 and black could maybe try
to play for the E5 Square so the Knight
on E7 is restricted maybe it's going to
be reduced to Knight C8 which is purely
a defensive task tot and Knight C8
relinquishes the grip on the F5 score so
Magnus perfectly timing the move H5
hikaro doing everything possible to
avoid playing G5 and allowing that
Knight on F3 to to sink its teeth into
the delicious F5 Square I think you have
to go G5 though uh by hook or by crook
you have to keep the F5 Square protected
and after white plays Knight D4 the
problem is that the Rook loses contact
with the D6 Square so black actually can
return to E7 of the Knight Hikaru still
holding on yeah the Knight on C8 is like
it's actually the only thing uh keeping
him in the game because it's guarding
the D6 pawn and when the F5 square is
threatened it's guarding the F5 Square
so left that kn on C8 big problems in
this position for Hikaru it looks easy
for Magnus to play but he's offered
maybe a trade and hikaro could have
snagged that Knight off the board now he
doesn't have that chance anymore he also
could have tried D5 but I think hikaro
is actually comfortable with this Pawn
structure he's telling himself Magnus is
burning a lot of clock and he hasn't
found a way to win the D6 Pawn yet let's
just kind of keep the status quo and
maybe Magnus will over press I don't
know if that's the way to to to do it
though because like you want to play D5
but I think you're going to need to
recapture with a pawn there agreed and
instead he's gone B5 sending the Knight
either back to E3 and again we're going
to see this Knight E7 classic but Knight
A5 is also very tempting attacking that
new Target on C6 that's a more Magnus
esque move I think no he drops back to
E3 okay I think Knight E7 Rook D well
yeah D2 D3 he goes on a light Square
just good good practice there and after
D5 he wants to play Rook D1 and the
pawns are going find themselves on fixed
dark squares for a potential end game
maybe with just dark Square Bishops but
D4 Hikaru slides his Pawn through B4
preventing C5 what a move obviously the
Knight is Untouchable there because the
Rook on D7 will hang and Magnus keeping
the status quo here with A3 he could
have taken A5 but I think he's trying to
surround the D Pawn with the move Knight
E3 to C2 which is a big Threat by the
way yeah and the the moves here that are
possible Knight d
just to showcase the pure Insanity of
how many things are hanging in that
position F5 has a similar idea Knight C2
there would have picked off the D4 Pawn
I think that was a big Miss by Magnus he
takes the pawn on F5 instead but Hikaru
R oh my gosh no there's Rook takes G7 in
the end and Bishop B5 Bishop B2 but the
king could sign step but you could go to
f8 I'm Tak Bishop D6 we're gonna have to
show this after the game or Karu might
play the move no
the time is too low we have to stay with
the action now it doesn't exist anymore
that was an insane line ofon we promis
to show this after the game no matter
how the game finishes feels like Magnus
is in the driver seat he can support the
F Pawn with G4 that's very scary
remember Bishop D4 Rook d8 you can't
just rush and take that and that's why
Magnus bringing his King up to E2
supporting the Rooks playing for a win
car big trouble also on the clock he's
got seven seconds and so many weaknesses
to defend here
yeah the king is going to be improved
maybe all the way over to
B3 BC just take it and take it oh he
didn't take walk into a permanent pin
but he doesn't want to do it but Bishop
takes threaten and Bishop F6 there was
easy Magnus allowing Hikaru to get
active again good point Rook C B6 is
coming though okay now it's suddenly a
three res game again I mean Magnus could
lose control of this game and let that
deep on through
o that I didn't expect that looks like a
good move Rook A5 it's not hanging what
a move Rook B6 maybe surround the B Pawn
and now a
trade check first it looks like keeping
both Rooks on the board was maybe more
dangerous uhoh King D3 oh the king comes
up rook B7 sending the king back and
Magnus has to find a way to infiltrate
hikaru's blockade oh Rook e two D3 oh my
gosh who has to be careful here it's oh
my goodness Rook F2 and he's going to
win the F3 pawn and I think Yaro might
hold this yep cuz if if the Rook could
get to E4 that would be different and
hikaro holding the E file he cannot let
the king infiltrate E6 oh this is
incredible he's hanging on by an actual
threat and he's doing it incredibly well
he just goes rookie one rookie two I
don't think Magnus has an easy way to
make progress if you're
Carlson careful where you put your
pieces yeah Rook G4 was too risky though
I agree with hikaro stay on the eile and
that's your defensive method and I think
we're going to get a draw Magnus just
not finding a single way to pose further
problems I don't think such a way exists
he can't put anything on the E file
hikaro is too solid I think Rook B4 is a
reasonable try yeah bring the Rook here
so at least that's taken care of but he
does it in a moment when Bishop E7 can
be played Bishop D4 Rook D1 pinning the
bishop moving the king back Magnus keeps
finding newer and newer ways to pose new
problems but he car The Rook end game is
drawn and it is especially with the King
cut off this way if the King was on D4
different story why did he let he's got
his King tap six and Magnus is going to
win no he's lost King G6 F6 it's over
it's an umbrella he's using the pawns as
a shield this is a loss oh my goodness
how many turnarounds F seven there was
winning on the spot as does
this and it's actually the presence of
the pawn that makes it a win because
otherwise black can play Rook takes f
six check and
stalemate and hikaro is annoyed he's
irritated and he has lost a critical
game allowing Magnus to tie the match
I'll give you the choice him on we can
show that amazing line earlier or we can
show how Magnus was able to turn this
game around at the end your call I think
we we stick with what happened uh stick
with what's fresh this ultimately was uh
the turnaround point I think it is
instructive because it it looked like a
total draw and Hikaru was making it a
total draw he was defending on seconds
on his clock the entire time I mean that
alone is such a tough task especially
against Magnus Carlson who's you know
right right up in your grill trying to
tie this match and look at this the King
was cut off Dan and I mean what what do
you think here you just had to leave The
Rook on the E file right well Rook e six
was an incredible practical move by
Carlson and what Hikaru had to do was
defend laterally he had to play the move
Rook to A1 and the point of that move is
that after Rook A1 King E4 uh it's not
even easy for me and I'm you know I see
the eval bar King G7 apparently was the
only move prevent what you have to do is
prevent the white king from reaching F6
if it reaches E5 you can now start
giving the lateral checks Rook A5 Rook
A6 wherever the King goes you pursue him
but how hard is this to figure out with
two seconds Hikaru made the natural move
Rook G1 he thought I'm tying myself to
the G Pawn the king can't move but it
can and it moves to F6 and now the white
pie activity overwhelms Black's defenses
all credit to Magnus how does he do this
it's amazing and the presence of Black's
G Pawn is the reason that this position
is actually lost I mean it having that
pawn here otherwise you could play Rook
takes F6 with a stalemate but that guy's
working for the other
team be still my baiting hardamon that's
all I have to say and what we have to
say for you folks is that we have 30
minutes of bullet to decide the SC final
this match is all tied at 9 a piece and
we are about to have some of the most
epic half an hour of action ever but
before we go on break and set the
players up for bullet we wanted to
remind you um and take a moment to thank
ag1 a new partner of the SEC ag1 is your
daily support of key Health functions
from mental performance to energy and
the immune system it's the one product
that does the work of many to find out
more visit drink a1.com or use exclam
ag1 we than ag1 we're sponsoring the SEC
well we'll let the players drink their
ag1 and they'll need a lot of it because
the SEC returns to determine a winner we
have 30 minutes of bullet coming up and
we will be back with more hikaro versus
Magnus action in just a couple
[Music]
moments
we first thought that we had experienced
the chess boom that had washed Over Us
in 2019 at the end of 2018 kind of going
into 2019 we kind of looked at oh well
that was guys that was the chess boom
and oh we're in a new level we it was
kind of then but then like literally
like Co happened we were ramping up so
quickly in each country that locked down
Italy India but you could see
registrations flying through as each
country lock down and it was all
happening so fast there was no like oh
this is so cool this was like oh my gosh
we're going
to we literally couldn't keep up and so
there was no like positive coolness out
of this it wasn't until like we were
into the you know pandemic and then like
several months and we're like oh wow
this okay well during the pandemic a
more people are going to play chess it
will die back down nope then came POG
champ
and what de talked about and we're like
oh my gosh then okay after that it no
okay and then came Queen's Gambit we're
like all right well that was definitely
the peak and and then the media started
writing about Chess and then okay where
is it going to stop we we have beens 3
you're just getting hit wave after wave
after wave and then there's the stuff in
the media now which just like wave and
like we almost can't even come up breath
fast enough to recognize this before
there's like another wave coming from
from this point on we just don't know
what to expect is there another way of
coming
[Music]
probably do you wish playing a chess
game with a friend was as easy as
sending them a text well good news now
it is with chess.com new iMessage app
you can start and play a game directly
in iMessage your friend doesn't even
need a chess.com account it's just tap
and play head over to go. chess.com
iMessage or use the command iMessage in
chat to learn
[Music]
more
there is there some sort of mate it's
mate G5 is coming and it's mate he car
has sack so it's two to two and that
means we are Level once more outside
chance
of oh the
queen take it I take the second time he
sees it the second time and now hit CaRu
has built his lead up and in addition to
his three-point lead he's got a really
nice position in this game he has to
rush this like he's never rushed before
yep 10 seconds here comes the
a he missed it match it's a tide match
hikaro should play for a win look at the
clock should and he knows it and he does
it hikaro going in wa there was a
blunder we'd be six yeah this part is
promoting he allowed the queen in the
part you see on mag face he knows it
does it is how hiar Nakamura defended
his bullet just championship title oh my
goodness that was a Clash of
[Music]
Titans
he is the 2023 bullet chess champion he
defeated Magnus Carlson in one of the
most incredible matches that we have
seen quadruple overtime and Hikaru
stands all tied up with Magnus the score
is 9 to9 in the speed chest Championship
final presented by coinbase we welcome
everybody who has been with us from the
start and we welcome everybody who's
just joined you come in at a great time
Grand masterm Hamilton we see a lot of
threel words that start with w and end
with
n h I think I can figure this one out
although uh my worldle needs a little
more practice uh yeah I the most notable
one there comes at the end Magnus
Carlson also a familiar name now this is
the perfect opportunity for Magnus to
get his quite literal Revenge because
this is hik Caro's wheelhouse Magnus
Carlson you know Undisputed you know the
greatest player maybe of all time but
certainly right now but guess what in
bullet Hikaru Nakamura is something else
and even Magnus knows he respects
hikaru's ability in bullet and we got a
great reminder of that in hikara
semi-final match against mvl Nakamura
was down a point going to the bullet he
won that match by five he was dominant
from wire to wire and the biggest
mistake by hikaru's admission that mvl
made is that he played too quickly this
is not 1 plus 0 this is 1 plus one and
what you want to avoid doing is over
adjust start out by playing too fast and
end with a minute on your clock Magnus
Carlson is one of the best at adjusting
to the new demands of the new
constraints of the time control folks
the score is 9 to9 we have 30 minutes of
one plus one action my voice is
quivering and this I mean was there ever
any doubt that we were going to be tied
going into the bullet was there ever an
actual doubt I mean it helps that you
know it's all scripted anyway for an
unbelievable finale and surprise
surprise that we're going to get it in
bullet Queen A5 this very trendy move
and we are off in the bullet portion
here but that plus one is going to give
Magnus a chance to hang with a bullet
Pro like iaro early signs Magnus playing
the first caroon of the match clearly
indicating that with black he wants to
play as solidly as possible he wants to
get structures that you're familiar with
and that becomes more important in the
bullet than in the blitz he wants
structures that you can play intuitively
as Hikaru there setting up a devilish
threat of Bishop takes H6 and you know
faking
Bop C is a threat and I think yukar got
the initiative in this G mhm and look
you're willing to actually make moves
like Knight H4 Bishop H7 um just Knight
back to F3 that's something that you
would probably frown at in a Blitz game
but in bullet no you're comfortable just
probing around and not necessarily
worried about every single move and
Magnus continuing to steer the game in
the direction that makes him comfortable
now he repeats moves with Queen G6 and
queen F5 he can play G5 and this bishop
off instead he expands on the other side
of the board and Hikaru does the same in
the center Queen B5 now threatens A4
Magnus says I'm not taking hikaru's
initiative sitting
down yeah I I mean Bishop H6 is one of
the moves to look at but it doesn't
really come with the next move Bishop E5
however F7 Pawn is loose as well Aman
that's a knife especially in bullet
because trading on E5 and dropping your
queen back I think Magnus might have to
go for that line but giving up F7 the
entire house of C might come down in the
center but Magnus has to bite the bullet
here what happens after Queen takes F7
is it
A4 Queen B6 exclamation mark and A4
great move by Carlson very heads up
targeting all of White's Pawns in the
center and we're going to get a Pacman
game here pretty shortly mhm and you
could take that but you could also take
on E6 the thing with E6 is that that Aon
actually might be dangerous down the
line Magnus could have thrown in Rook f8
for starters but that would have
involved giving up the E6 Pawn speaking
of Pacman who's going to take more pawns
here I think it's actually going to be
white in the end white might emerge with
an extra a pawn and a weak Pawn on
E6 wow that's quite a move there sort of
walking into it almost but Queen D2 is
the next move and these Rooks yeah they
defend each other but they can't move in
a Blitz game you would take White's
position with open arms but in the
bullet segment you have to defend
against all these annoying threats black
has a bit of an initiative on the king
side he can also Drive his ewn up to E4
potentially and Magnus does a gr he
Mouse slipped what was
that what did he mous slip no it wasn't
a mous slip he was expecting Queen takes
C6 and he was hovering over that square
what are you doing you've got 15 seconds
yeah that's uh that's such a classic
type of bullet blunder not a mouse slip
as you said but just you expect the
queen to show up there and when any
piece shows up on E6 you're ready to
take it yeah you can't prevent your like
animal brain from executing the move the
problem isn't that it's that Magnus was
hovering over that square trying to do a
little bit too much that time and after
an amazing job navigating a dubious
position Magnus drops his Queen and he
drops the first bullet game and man oh
man does he need to strike back in this
one he does like that's quite literally
the worst way to start this uh segment
however I do like his position here I
think in bullet uh for the white pieces
especially looking at that F5 Square I
think he's got a pretty good practical
position very promising as he heads back
to E1 with his other Knight and hearo
there with B5 trying to prevent the D2
knight uh from getting to the E3 square
that is ideal real estate because you're
accessing both F5 and D5 and I think we
are going to see Knight C2 by Magnus but
look at what iar is doing him on he is
trying to play really really actively to
compensate for his lack of control in
the center and he's doing an amazing job
of it so
far yeah even though um I like what
hikaro has done here I still think that
Magnus is kind of executing this
long-term positional plan uh and that
Bishop if it gets left over with some
pawns on the same color I I actually
really like the way this is going for
Magnus God he's faked us out so many
times but finally we see Knight C2 E3 is
not the only Transit point you can also
fly through the B4 International Airport
and he actually recaptures with the pawn
yeah I agree him on B3 might be coming
soon but Rook D6 and he's blundered
because if you trade you blunder the
fork on D2 and it turns around is
happening anyway oh my gosh it's just
lost Pawn takes and then Knight's hit
and Knight D2 and the decision to take
back with the pawn was a really bad one
here comes the other KN bang bang bang
and hikaro is crushing Magnus in the end
game I think uh you know the the secrets
out it was not the shirt it was the it
it was a blitz shirt I think he needed
to put his bullet shirt on yeah maybe
the original shirt and now Magnus is
dropping everything Knight takes G2 and
Knight to D2 yeah and C takes before was
when the wheels came off Magnus
outsmarting himself there Aman A little
bit yeah that almost looked uh like too
cute
fancy whoa BC huh BC and Hikaru wants to
go C3 he's taken with a bishop what's
going on here okay Bishop back now and
then C2 Rook A1 Rook seems unnecessary
by both sides there something very
strange was going on in this game hikaro
goes for this end game he's going to go
A3 I think but Bishop D2 is an amazing
move because after A2 King B2 you drop
the a pawn and Magnus finds the most
complicated to move of all instantly
incredible he had it he had it all
planned it's a draw how did he sa that
he's going to play H4 King E6 I would
have said first but yes just going to be
a draw here a that's a huge save hearo
might extend this game though as long as
possible you're not really it's I mean
you can milk the clock you're only up a
point but this would be consistent with
his
strategy yeah I would say here don't
really know if that's his strategy
because he's he's confident in bullet
right he's not trying to shy away from
anything no no but he is showing a
desire to extend this game as long as
possible I think if you're hiar you do
want this to go down to the wire you you
thrive in these high press situations
and so he's going to get another 30
seconds 45 seconds off the clock also
Magnus is the one who has to remain on
his toes because the Knight is the more
dangerous piece in these
situations or will Magnus make me eat my
words you said what yeah nothing nothing
you heard something maybe you need to
replace your headphones F5 by Hikaru
still
trying yeah he can extend this game he's
going to be able to play Knight F4 or E4
if he wants so uh match strategy clearly
uh revealed well 8 minutes have already
been lopped off the match clock yaru
wins the first bullet game I thought we
were on like game one or two here what's
going on yeah we were still on break a
second ago and now there's 22 minutes
left this is what Hikaru is going for
and is he trying to lose this game King
D5 yeah he has to be a little careful
here girl oh KN barely surviving this
he's down to like having to find only
moves now but he is finding them yeah
that's that he does that you know
sometimes once in a while come on I'm on
don't overstate the case here this isn't
the SEC finals or anything
oh wow so clever he's one a pun how I
don't
know Bishop C5 uh Bishop to d8 got it oh
my gosh now suddenly White's the one who
has to be careful Knight F4 is coming it
really feels like someone oh Knight F2
he's gonna win or is
he regardless of whether he's going to
win it's phenomenal that he's done what
he's
done how how is he up a pawn from that
end game it's it's it's you you watch
the moves I see the moves I my brain
processes the moves and I still can't
understand how we have a two-on-one and
and the worst thing is Hikaru can now
milk another minute off the clock that's
right and Knight D5
threatened yep and he can just Shuffle
that night around there's no big urgency
that's such a that's such a devilish
little move cuz Magnus could have very
easily pre moved a king move
there totally hold it now but it's still
hard hikaro getting his King
around yeah King F5 Bishop E5 there's
some H3 Knight F4 stuff and finally
Magnus is going to bag the H3 pawn and
bag the G5 pawn and force this game this
NeverEnding game to end and Hikaru is
still keeping the pawn on the board
I think 97 97 yeah of course and now
wait five seconds and then take the
queen maximum squeeze totally and let's
let's not uh sugarcoat it that wasn't
just a maximum squeeze H in a
gamesmanship way uh no he was playing
for a win there in case you forgot and
he was briefly winning according to the
eval bar if he had moved the Knight to
F2 but that ship has sailed and they
repeat an opening that we saw quite a
bit in the three-minute portion a
sicilian with a bishop on C3 I don't
love the way this starts for Hikaru I
mean Magnus just seems to have gotten a
very very nice setup here yep yep A3 and
C3 you can see the desperation to get
that Bishop back to C3 yeah get rid of
that pawn Magnus and Magnus says no I
will
not Bishop E3 I mean again hoping to
have B take C3 played I I still feel
like um Magnus is really really happy
with how this is started but he's got to
figure out a way to protect the D7 Pawn
either directly or indirectly as he's
done now he can castle look at this
tactical Awareness on Queen takes D7
Rook d8 traps the queen that's such a
hard idea to see and bullet and it was
because of Queen B8 covering the the C7
Square so he totally planned that I
would put the queen on C7 though to give
the Rook a little bit more latitude
along the eighth rank maybe later you
can play Rook A8 Magnus burning a lot of
clock here and this is what he was
spending it on what a sacrifice and e4's
hanging the B3 Bishop is under Fire he
car's got to be really careful to keep
his position together here yeah maybe
okay yeah this is probably more what
Magnus was looking for two Bishops
imbalanced Pawn structure don't take
with a knight don't take with a knight
Bishop A4 wins the piece and iaru sees
it yeah but this is fantastic for the
Bishops right exactly what you want
Magnus this is precisely the kind of
position that we're used to seeing him
winning regularly E5 Bishop
C6 yeah Knight B5 Bishop C6 Knight F3
you could just take it I think
that's oh he wants to play the Bishops
cuz there was one school of thought you
know just take Rook takes B3 but maybe
that position is just objectively very
hard to win well Magnus wants to take
ukar to school in this end game and I
think he thinks Aman that you can win
the B3 Pawn on demand so he wants to
extract more out of the position maybe
milk White's clock down but he's milking
his own clock down as a
result F5
F4 okay he's going to just defend for
now but going very aggressive now Magnus
has over pressed before and he's over
pressed again or has he because Bishop
F2 runs into Rook A1 but there's the
move B4 and hearu missed it B4 would
have kept the C5 Pawn defended now it
should be technically winning for
Carlson mm he keeps the Rooks on I don't
know whether that was a a chance to to
trade it off I I think hear made the
right choice though D5 now is going to
come with devastating effect look at
Black's Pawn f links not over yet though
yar's Rook is very very active and if
you push your pawns prematurely Bishop
D4 wow is he just going to try to like
stay in this position as okay he's
giving H7 and Rook A6 there's Rook B6
and that spells
trouble but is this
winning it
is that was quick it is but not easy
look at Hikaru using every last resource
but he's just not fast
King C2
now oo yeah Bishop E3 and Bish G
remember there's like this H pawn bishop
configuration on the H1 Square oh D2
apparently that was wrong
E5 oh my gosh this is so close to a draw
all of a sudden
H6 amazing wow but how do you win this
you do get your king back to G4 yeah
Bishop C3 and now you just walk and
you'll have to play G7 and then you're
playing what these two pawns against the
bishop how does that work am on I don't
think I would have found H6 in a
classical game that is inhuman to leave
the protected passer on G3 G7 and now
it's finally completely winning or is it
not but yeah yeah you really have to
work again here though this is very
color Pawn but he's going to get the
bishop
off I mean that win was truly insane we
are looking at a match between two of
the best players in the world and one of
them Happ to mnus Carlson who's a wizard
in the end game you talk about he cars
bullet prowess how about magnus's end
games considering that they had 10
seconds on their clock no it wasn't
Flawless yes hearo almost got back in
the game which is incredible on its own
merits but the way that Magnus found H6
and handled walked on hot coals there is
amazing and we have another R Lopez and
another Kings Indian like structure with
a very early C5 Push by Magnus yeah in
another tied match 10 and 1/2 10 and 1/2
talking about it going down to the wire
we're halfway through this match and
guess what it has the makings of that
you know photo finish oh it absolutely
does you know this is going to be a
photo finish halfway through the one
minute portion and Carlson sacking the
pawn there H CaRu could have advanced it
to F4 and taken on C5 but in the Kings
Indian Aman this is a very standard way
to sack in order to open up the queen
side now with White's control over the
E4 Square I think Magnus has the upper
hand yeah and this um Bishop on E3 I
mean it makes sense to take but as soon
as you do the Knight will return to the
D4 square that you once uh had covered
yeah it's like playing uh you know
knockout basketball you knock someone's
ball out they get angry and they're like
I'm going to come back and knock your
ball out but kn4 doesn't tell the whole
story because white also controls the C
file there is am the idea of an exchange
sacrifice on D4 potentially could go
Rook C4 Rook takes D4 so I still think
Magnus he car rather has the shorter end
of the stick and he's given up H6 o yeah
and it looks like Knight D4 takes there
was Knight E2 but a lot of Pawns fall in
that position I actually think
practically this is a very hard position
for Magnus to handle and he's handling
it
incredibly didn't even realize it was
hanging there what a move Queen H4 he
car spoted that in like a nan but he
could couldn't take on G6 there because
of Rook G3 Magnus secures the pawn and
can he go down the C file with Queen C3
Queen C7
true yeah going with the queen makes
more sense you actually have some
threats like Queen H7 there but you're
also giving away the F2 Pawn in the
process G7 Hikaru allowing Queen C1 I
think that might
win yeah if the Rook goes to C8 it's
over but he decides to take however what
do you do about this Pawn this is a
serious problem hikaro has to keep the
D6 Pawn protected Magnus helping himself
to another pawn queen takes A6 hikaro
doing everything he can to up White's
King but I think Magnus has enough back
Queen F1 and queen E1 Queen F1 that's
the move and it's totally winning too
many extra pawns here now the queen has
to go back and you can basically serve
up a distraction on the a file black two
pieces need to be near the king sloppy
there by Magnus Queen to E6 would have
been an easier win he plays it now
hikaro could have actually snagged the
pawn on G7 but it was lost anyway and
Magnus is back on
top wow just like that Magnus flips the
script if I'm remembering correctly
Hikaru started out with that win right
because Magnus you know effectively some
kind of brain slipped his Queen right
and that's how things started but this
is how they're going and currently
Magnus has retaken that lead it probably
feels good because he hasn't had it in a
while which is crazy to say given how
the match started we're getting another
end game and in the early going Aman I'm
not suggesting that he car was bad at
end games but Carlson is getting exactly
the kinds of positions that he really
really wants in the last couple of games
that's right that's right and now hiar
down in the match you know might have to
shift uh the strategy because what was
working for you before might not be
applicable anymore but he's trying to
work on Black's Center obviously black
is the bishop pair but the kingside pawn
structure is really weak and the D5 Pawn
is weak I think we're going to get some
sort of major liquidation here Rook
takes D5 there's Bishop to E6 so Magnus
might actually play down a pawn here for
for a bit oh Bishop F4 almost wins an
exchange but the Knight blocks yeah and
you have to be careful of Bishop E3 Pawn
E3 it looks like you're shattering
White's Pawn structure but the bishop
against the Knight is not favorable for
black so if white can liquidate these
pawns over here I think B3 is not crazy
just to make sure you get that nasty Aon
off the board oh absolutely and that's
precisely what hikaro will focus on I
think a draw here is likely although I
keep saying that and then crazy stuff
keeps happening in the end game we're
going to see the on E3 no Magnus is
playing for a win here he's keeping both
of his Bishops on the board I think on
you called it I would take and go B3 if
I'm hear y mhm same idea B3 now and okay
this is what I'm wondering is Magnus now
not going to acquest to the draw because
okay maybe I prefer the Knight but do I
prefer the Knight when I'm down in the
match like playing this on for any
reason so Aman I think as long as both
Rooks are on the board I actually prefer
black because his Rooks are more active
I think white is the one who has to
exercise caution now if the Knight lands
on H5 then the script flips as as you
said earlier but right now I think
Magnus is still playing this on the
merits of the
position right y makes sense or needs to
keep those Rooks on the board and he
goes back to A1 and he can just move the
king like King G6 or something and and
continue oh my goodness 11 minutes left
in the bullet segment hearo down by one
first of all he needs to hold this POS
position he cannot afford a l here and I
think he's doing an excellent job of
defending this essentially from a
position of strength I think it's time
to repeat moves or is hekaro going for
it
now I don't think hikaro is going I
think Magnus is saying hey you want to
play positions out let's play positions
out I'm happy to do it now that I have
uh the edge in the match and now he
trades Rooks this obviously increases
the likel hit of a draik CaRu preventing
F5 and fixing Black's pawns on weak
squares but that King on G6 is ideally
placed to keep everything under a lock
and key this one is going to
liquidate yeah I I immediately saw E4
and I was like I'm not sure if I like
that move but if the the idea is to
liquidate and just get out of this game
as fast as possible it makes total sense
it does indeed Hikaru still making
threats there oh and he can take E6 and
take F6 and take G6 but that is a drawn
Rook end game and it's almost like if
you get into that end game Magnus is
down upon but he's happy cuz the game
will go for a while totally and look
we're under 10 minutes in the match now
a draw is all but guaranteed and Hikaru
trying to keep pieces on the board this
move E5 tells me that Hikaru is still
entertaining hopes of some sort of night
Fork but it's unrealistic yeah how if
you move the night there's Rook E4
always so it feels like uh there's just
no progress to be made and not to
mention the age Pawn is just loose and
Hikaru keeps trying to find ways to keep
the game going but it's finally a draw
and Magnus maintains his onepoint lead
and has the white pieces with which he's
been able to put major pressure in the
last segment of this match and it goes
without saying that with less than 10
minutes to go don't think of these
bullet games Dan as like oh 2 minutes
for that game 2 minutes for that game no
these bullet games with plus one second
they can go five six minutes remember we
had a game that looked like it was
taking like six plus minutes and we were
like wait a minute did this just segment
just start yeah this is not like the
bullet brawl where you can get 10 games
in the last 5 minutes and look at hikaro
I think he of all people senses the
urgency and he says I'm going to go for
magnus's throat and I think he's doing a
great job of it Magnus has misplayed the
opening Queen E8 Queen H5 it's an easy
position to play and that is the main
thing which makes white have a
difficulty here totally and look at this
bishop takes C6 hearo doesn't care he
says go ahead and win that pawn I mean
at this point I may consider C5 but um
yeah he was happy to give it up and play
on what I was expecting to be the king
side but Magnus is trying to say hey
Focus over here don't forget about my
king Magnus is doing an amazing job of
deflecting hikaro from the King side to
the queen side which he's opened up and
look at Magnus making strides and trying
to infiltrate Rook C7 with threaten a
potential M on H7 and Hikaru has to sh
the queen away but down goes the pawn
and Rook takes D6 just as a practical
bullet move is right around the corner
so don't forget about that
Rook F6 that's a sad necessity for
Nakamura I think you're exactly right
keeping his Center protected but giving
Magnus an important Tempo that he uses
to bring his Rook back to the seventh
rank maybe D5 although there is a rook
C6 move yeah he gets out of the way of
that The Rook needs to move watch out
Rook takes A2 I would throw that in if
I'm Hikaru just get rid of that pass
pawn and now any in game is going to be
more defensible for black I think he's
making strides to take over this game
once again Bishop H3 Knight H4 is a nice
shot and he plays it anyway and gets the
other Knight to F3 the F5 Square watch
out for that square if you're hikaro
mhm this is really well played by Magnus
right now even though he might not be
maximizing his Advantage he just wants
to neutralize what hearo is trying to
drum up on the king side he definitely
has the initiative but Bishop E7 is such
a ky move Look At That Knight on H4 it's
kind of stranded and you're not playing
G3 anytime soon because that loosens up
the other Knight it's very much a three
game absolutely this is unclear to the
max Queen
D5 uhoh uhoh Rook f8 Rook takes E7 I
would take I would take and just take D6
it's bullet just get things off the
board that was winning am on because of
the fork threat on G6 instead he puts
Piggies on the seventh and this is still
very difficult for
Nakamura oh that's a depressing move to
play Rook E8 sort of admitting that the
tactics aren't working for black but
Rook G7 is exquisite defensive play The
Rook on E8 is now guarded by the queen
but what do you do everything is barely
holding on unb there goes a minor piece
that's hanging is there is there Rook
takes G2 oh my gosh there's Rook H7
there as a result hikaro going all in
sacking the piece wow but Queen D3 is
going to
stabilize amazing Queen D3 holds
absolutely everything Rook G3 there was
again Rook H7 uhoh Queen H6 threatened
he car defends the queen can shuttle
trampolining back and forth threatening
m Galore Rook F7 trading Rooks winning
winning and he's he's going to resign
immediately yep he knows he needs to
resign he needs the next game to get
underway is not full panic mode yet but
this game is super important if it's a
long drawn out game especially if it's a
draw this might be it for hikaro
Nakamura I think he's now officially
thinking of this as a must-win game and
it's interesting to me that he keeps
repeating this weird Bishop C4 line in
the Sicilian now it makes sense though
because at the very least you're
guaranteeing an unbalanced
game yep you and this is an improvement
from last time remember Bishop C3 those
positions weren't working out instead
he's going back to what is worked Queen
H5 he might be trying to really drum up
an attack and Magnus says no and it goes
without saying that Nakamura keeps his
Queens on the board I like the setup a
lot more uh with his Pawn on C3 and more
space than he did in the previous
Sicilian game but Magnus classic
Sicilian maneuver and now we have a more
standard type of shenan structure yeah
there is H4 it needs to happen we might
see Knight H2 Rook D3 Rook G3 uh I I
like it from Nakamura he can turn it on
when when he needs a result and look the
attacking games have worked for him
against Magnus so far oh my goodness
pandemonium on the board we keep seeing
Magnus advance that deep on but from a
practical perspective I think Rook G3 is
an excellent move there's a lot of
threats to deal with and am on don't
sleep on the C2 Bishop white could play
e takes D5 and queen D3 and if the black
king sides steps to h8 I think that
might be a huge issue so he goes the
other way yep I wonder if it's time to
remove this bishop with Bishop G5 cuz
you could also just bring the bishop all
the way back you're not worried about
Bishop D4 H6 is your next idea you're
opening things up and bringing the black
king to the center of the board where
it's going to be exposed and the best
news yet is that he has 50 seconds on
his clock as Magnus with some crazy T
move all about Bishop takes B2 he wants
Bishop takes D4 and the C2 Bishop is
going to hang but what I don't like
about this move is that iaru can ignore
everything go H6 and tear black to
shreds on the king side this looks scary
and this is exactly where Nakamura has
found success attacking magnus's King H7
H7 wow wining the only move but how do
you continue from there Queen B7 Queen
B7 and Knight C6 oh and then Knight C6
whoa wow and he's going to win Queen
takes C8 is winning you can give up E1
with check and just sidestep with King
H2 and the H Pawn Queens what the heck
is Knight F5 trying to get black to play
EF so white could take the queen with
check but Queen takes H7 and Magnus is
still in the game the pawn is hanging
take missed he doesn't see it Bishop
A3 where is he going he's going for a
jog nerves that was complely lost and
iaru is laughing because Aman after
Queen takes H7 it was winning but it was
still a game andar wins the first game
on demand and he I think maybe it is dry
smile cuz he's like okay you know we got
exactly what the people want we got one
more game and I think it's still
possible that it could be a draw and we
get another game but highly unlikely
very good chance that this is the final
game of the match and a must- win for
hekar Nakamura and he unbalances the
game immediately he plays E4 E5 but he
puts his Knight on E7 he tries to get
opposite side castling but he's already
in trouble because you can't Castle
short you're going to drop the H6 Pawn
so I don't like what he's gotten here
early on the Knight can land on D5 this
is a Carlson type of position it is but
you know what you got to cut uh hikaro
some slack here because he needs an
imbalanced position and sometimes you
have to just take a bad position
straight up and then turn it into a good
one later so at the very least it's not
some sort of equal game that's going to
be a draw and I like what he's doing
he's gotten his King to relative safety
he could strike with F5 and create
tension in the center that's a very
thematic idea in these types of
positions am on instead playing this
more defensively though with Rook C8
Knight D4 yeah and I think Magnus is
also uh he's looking like he wants to go
for some trades here Bishop A2 and queen
E6 is going to pick up the pawn what a
shot no way and now hikaro with a
clearly better position up a full pawn
and White's King has been
breached yeah and now with the with the
time getting as low on the match clock
this is it guys this game needs to be a
win for hikaro and he set himself up to
do it but he's got the hardest task
still ahe ofon because if he goes for
the queen trade try winning that
opposite colored Bishop end game against
Magnus Carlson hiar says out of the
question I'm keeping the Kings on the
board but Magnus keeps improving his
position
whoa he wants one eventually y Oh I
thought he should have played F5
there that would have been very
interesting but instead he's just
looking to simplify okay A5 Rook A1 B6
the pawns are going to go in dark
squares King is going to go to B7 what a
move by Hikaru shutting down WI strook
and Magnus has to bring everything back
I think the position is now getting
worse yep he car is playing really well
because he's the Rooks were too advanced
on the king side like what are they
doing Magnus bring them back and King B7
another amazing move Nakamura says hey
you want to attack down the a file no no
no no no I'm the boss down the a file
Magnus doing everything he can to
distract Nakamura here comes the queen
here come the mat Dire Straits for
Magnus he's on the ropes I don't even I
don't even know what to recommend here
Queen C1 Rook A2 it's insane I I can't
find a move hearu is doing it he's got
15 seconds to find a move and Magnus
closes his eyes and goes all
inness Rook A2 he missed it oh my
goodness Rook takes B6 again Rook takes
B6 and it's over Rook takes it's all
over oh my goodness he still has
something maybe Rook C7 for draw both
Rooks are
sacrificed oh my might be winning by the
way but he only needs a draw as the
match clock expires and hearo is
exasperated oh my gosh am on hikaro had
forced mate and it's a draw by agreement
and it's the match he offers a draw a
gentleman's draw and I mean what a
finish it literally comes down to the
last game and look at the smile on even
hikaru's face these guys are just two
Titans two Champions going at one
another you cannot script this any
better before we do anything before we
even congratulate Magnus we have to show
that last chance for hekar because he
had Rook A1 which is such a difficult
move to see and this game after this
game after Magnus missed the first
opportunity to sacrifice The Rook so
this is later Queen C2 yeah and if we
could pull pull up the board here yeah
Rook ea8 is what lost the SEC final Aman
take it away what would have been the
win truly truly incredible fashion here
Queen C2 gets a double question mark and
fittingly Rook to A2 I'm going to have
to award a brilliancy uh King takes A2
Rook A8 and you clear the way for the
queen to use the A1 square that was what
hear nakimura needed to find that was
the difference between us being in a
tiebreaker right now and Magnus Carlson
being the SEC Champion what an
incredible finish I mean you cannot
script this any better I'm speechless
but we got more talking to do and The
Savvy move of the game will come in this
last game so keep it pulled up him on
but here is the the final score last
year it was a onepoint victory for
Nakamura this year it's a one-point
victory for Magnus Carlson Aman is there
any way than that stat to symbolize how
incredible these players are every time
they play the same thing happens it's in
insane action from the first minute to
the last it is like it honestly feels uh
right for this match to be decided by
one point it it doesn't even matter in
which direction because it has been
you know hi Caro's match before it's
been magnus's match and these two are at
the top of chess for a reason certainly
at the top of online speed chess they
always meet in the finals and I mean
hikaro Nakamura only loses to one person
and that's Magnus Carlson my gosh there
is no Netflix show there is no activity
Amon that I would have rather been doing
the last couple of hours than watch this
insane match we congratulate Magnus
Carlson on his victory and for our
coinbase Savvy move of the day on let me
know if you disagree but I think we need
to go right back to our last game and I
think the Savvy move or shall I say The
Savvy moves have to be magnus's Rook
sacrifices because that is ultimately
what won him the match totally um I mean
this this game right here was the entire
match just encapsulated into one game
Rook D7 was played by Magnus he's
chasing the king he knows that you know
he's about to lose the game with Rook A2
coming but instead he comes up with a
very Savvy set of moves not only one
sacrifice Rook takes C5 seemingly giving
away The Rook for nothing but Rook to C7
check how's that for a Savvy move to
secure an SEC title Daniel using one
Rook to break apart Black's uh
protective Pawn cover the other Rook to
deflect the king and Magnus realizing
that mate is inevitable offer to draw
hikaro had no chance no choice but to
accept because the king is cornered and
that folks is how Magnus Carlson won one
of the most epic matches I've ever seen
the speed chest Championship 2023
belongs to Magnus Carlson but how many
Hoops did he have to jump through to get
the crown not just Yaro but everybody
else whom he had to
defeat amazing stuff I mean I obviously
can't wait to hear from these players
but this was the match that you know we
it was hyped up to be it always lives up
to the height uh I mean I was just most
intrigued by that final shot of both
players kind of giving that champion
Smile as they just I think they're just
realizing that they're the best
competitors for one another and it's
such an amazing rivalry to watch it
really is and it seems like every one of
their matches has so many twists and
turns it's never wired a wire it's never
a blowout it's always one person has the
moment momentum out of the gates and
then another person and the fact that we
had so many different openings on we had
the r Lopez stage the fact that this
match can even be divided into stages
tells us how epic it is is and you know
what else is epic it's the interview
that we will have with Magnus Carlson we
will hear the Winner's thoughts on this
amazing Unforgettable match and we will
set Magnus up folks do not go anywhere
the interview with Magnus in the speed
chest Championship presented by coinbase
coming right
up hold on to your Tes beginning
December 9th the Champions chess tour
finals are coming to Toronto Canada
Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura and Notre
Becka dorov have already secured their
spots in the finals thanks to their
beauty victories on the tour so far
super GM's Fabiano kowana Wesley so and
Ali Resa fua have secured enough points
to clinch spots as well as young Prodigy
Dennis lavic only one spot remains up
for grabs leavon aronian currently holds
the last qualifying spot on the
leaderboard but nothing is for sure as
several players remain in contention
including division one participants Yan
napesi Anish giri Maxim Vash grav and
shakar mamadov the players will have to
Giver in The Knockout rounds of the
final event the AI cup beginning on
September
25th
[Music]
I've worked with the two players perhaps
with the best chess intuition ever
Magnus Carlson and vishy
ARA this course is generally about
examples like this common knowledge
that's used on on the highest
level good intuition comes from knowing
a lot of examples from having seen
examples thought thought about them and
perhaps tried to implement the
principles but under different
circumstances having thought about it
having tried to implement it in a way
and having debated it so that's more or
less what I try to do at this
course basically puts the foundation for
positional understanding positional
intuition you would see in in many
[Music]
players everyone loves playing chess and
everyone loves chess club but there's
also a time and a place for playing all
your favorite games hey we're trying to
have a lesson here you need to get out
of here recently more kids have been
playing chess than ever in school but
sadly we've learned that they may not
always be playing chess at the most
appropriate
time well it might be sometimes okay to
grab a game between classes or if your
teacher gives you permission and hasn't
given you an assignment it's not okay to
be playing chess in school when you
aren't supposed to and chess should
never come between you taking your study
seriously and cooperating with your
fellow students and
teachers chess over the board or on the
phone is a great way to spend time with
friends but let's make sure that this
school year we don't let too much chess
happen in the classroom focus on your
school cuz chess.com will always be
there when class is over chess is school
your school all right that was awesome
everybody great job look what I did
Danny did you spell that yeah can we get
some other letters please what's wrong
with it
[Music]
Magnus Carlson is the 2023 speed chess
champion after a 5-year period in which
iaro Nakamura instituted hegemony over
the SEC Magnus reprises his victory from
2016 and 2017 and he is the SEC Champion
once more Magnus joins us in the studio
for an interview first question Magnus
when that final game ended I guess two
questions were you aware that that was
going to be the final game of the match
and second what how would you
characterize the emotions that flow
through your mind when the match
ended um yeah I was just
uh
um yeah I realized like towards the end
of the penultimate game that if
um well that the the next game would
very likely be the be the last so uh at
least if I if it was not a very short
game uh and
um yeah uh I mean after I blundered the
pwn on A2 after that I couldn't keep uh
control uh at all and I mean I thought I
was lost uh for sure and then I just
gave a
check uh and I realized only like after
giving the check that well it looks like
I have a Perpetual now or at least a
Perpetual so yeah that was was a bit
lucky like mentally a few minutes before
I was thinking that H this is going to
be uh we're going to be here for another
half an hour um but uh yeah I was just
so happy so relieved that um that I
found that shot and that I managed to
yeah to finish the match off eventually
well Magnus I mean congratulations uh
from me as well what a match I think a
theme that we were noticing throughout
the match I don't know if you felt this
way as well but when hikaro was just
kind of throwing caution to the win and
just attacking your king straight up
those were the games that he was finding
a lot of success is that something that
you noticed uh over the match that when
he just sort of went all out for these
crazy attacks that they were just
working
yeah I I actually think he sort of could
have done that even earlier uh because I
was not in good shape today I mean I
could feel it I could feel it at the
start I could feel it before the start
really the whole day that I was not
going to be anywhere near the level that
I was against against Wesley um and I I
did feel very
lucky that he wasn't really trying
harder to punish me at
at the start and
um when he eventually started to to win
games then I was just thinking that uh
yeah this
is I mean I didn't think that I was in
any kind of uh kind of shape to to
withstand the the pressure and we went
into the break in the
3-1 uh he just like I think think then
he just won that Berlin ending where I
was much better then he found some very
good resources to stay a float and
somehow I managed to lose instead of
draw uh towards the end in general I
would say that I was not
like uh keeping my head calm whatsoever
in scrambles uh which was also which was
also a problem I don't think he was
great in scrambles either uh today but
that's usually a good indication of
whether your brain is working and mine
would just shut off um during during
scrambles while for instance against
Wesley I would still sort of be thinking
and um um coming up with decent
moves Magnus hearkening back to the
moment uh after you got off to the four
and a half half start in the three plus
one you were down by three going into
the break what specific adjustments did
you make during the break because it it
seemed like your play looked a little
bit different it seemed like you made
some adjustments in order to tie the
match going to the bullet what did you
tell yourself and how did you set
yourself up mentally to make that
comeback in the 3+ one
segment yeah I mean I started to check
um the games a bit that I I'd lost and
then I thought yeah that's in the past
uh that's fine also I I thought that
yeah my mind was Heating so I should
change to something a little bit lighter
um I had the banana and also I think not
a carrot this time actually uh but uh I
just thought that even though I mean I
was losing games like he was just uh he
was just completely crushing me at that
point I I did feel that I mean from last
year and from the
Championship this year that um that I I
know that I I could come back from
reasonable deficits so deficit so I knew
that it was all about whether my brain
could start working like if my brain
could start working at some point I knew
I would have I would have some kind of
chance
um and
um um yeah I mean I got a much needed
win with black the next game I um
I mean in terms of whether I change and
anything like I was messing around with
both like Sicilians and E5 and I thought
that was getting decent positions in
general so it was just matter of matter
of taste
really well Magnus taking a step back
and just thinking about what this result
means overall I mean can you speak about
what it means to you uh you know winning
the SEC and of course of course doing it
against hearo you guys have had such a
rivalry it's literally only been you two
that win the SEC so I mean what does it
mean to you to win the event uh again
and reclaim that and also against hearo
is such a competitor for
you so I I mean my my goal um for this
season also for the last two seasons has
been very clear uh to sort of in a in a
major way sort of
reestablish the pecking order when it
comes to comes to speed chess and um and
to be honest I
failed miserably in that like losing
two uh like very um even matches against
taru and and Maxim uh and uh winning one
by by one point so um
yeah as I said I didn't
feel good like going into today but
still I'm not at all satisfied with my
performance I feel that I can do um I I
can do a lot better and I do feel that
if I played the way that I played
against Wesley then um you know this
wouldn't have been close so in that
sense you know I'm I'm happy to get the
win
but winning should be
like I should win most of the time
so
I uh so yeah obviously like when when
you played such a match it feels so much
better to to to win then to lose so I'm
happy and relieved about that but I
still haven't managed to achieve my goal
really in the speed chest Championship
um which I did the first two two years
so I think there's uh still definite
history to be to be written
there well that history will continue
next year Magnus speaking of History I
think this is a great segue to a few
chat questions before we let you take
your well-deserved rest uh a question
from bin TV which young player Magnus do
you see becoming as good as yor Hikaru
in the SEC in the future uh keeping in
mind the blitz time controls and keeping
in mind all of the young talents who are
terrorizing the classical field these
days I think it's uh it's I mean the
answer is pretty obvious that it's Alesa
FIA uh he has clearly the highest uh
potential um and uh to be
honest I thought at this point that he
would be if not quite at the same level
than very very close and actually When
you mention these young players and I
mentioned ala my feelings like today
remind me a little bit of 2020 when I
lost the band Blitz Cup Final to to Ala
also in a very even match um I did play
him like a few weeks later um in
the uh in the Magnus imitational in
Rapid and I won a very very close match
there and that didn't satisfy me at all
I had some of the same feelings still
that the only thing that would sort of
count as revenge for me was a decisive
Victory and I I couldn't get that but uh
so uh no I think Alesa clearly has the
eyes potential um Nial is very strong uh
I'm sure he can improve as
well um as for the other kids uh would
be interesting to see in a couple years
if prag could could be um could be a
contender in this format of satov as
well who knows but um for the moment um
Alesa is a little bit away uh and the
others are um far
away well continuing with the chat
questions Magnus and bringing us back to
the match a little bit I admit I wanted
to know the answer to this as well but
we have a chat question from Robert Bazi
who says uh Magnus was it the change of
shirts that brought you back in the game
because you know whether or not uh it
was intentional you changed your shirt
you came in and won a bunch of games in
a row and got right back in the
match um yeah I mean I I guess it helped
that it cooled me down a little bit just
wearing something lighter as I spoke
about earlier and I I I guess I made
plus four with this shirt and minus
three with the other so the result sort
of speaks for
itself well Magnus final question before
we let you go any overall Reflections
from this year's SEC and how much are
you looking forward to next year's
Edition can we sign you up
preemptively yeah I can just repeat what
I what I said earlier that um you know I
happy to Havey to win uh it's better to
win then to lose but I'm I'm not
satisfied so I'm going to be I'm going
to be back and um hoping to um
establish establish the dominance that I
I
think I
can well Magnus we always appreciate
your Insight we appreciate the effort
and we definitely appreciated this
incredible match congratulations on the
speed Chess Championship and we can't
wait to to see what you will bring to
the table next year congrats mag thank
you guys so always appreciate to you as
well thank you very much that was Magnus
Carlson another Victory among another
feather in his cap he has had a chip on
his shoulder for what seems like the
last year online over the board he's got
a lot of gas left in the tank doesn't he
he really does but I mean just thinking
about what we just witnessed it was uh
down to the actual wire match between
simply two of the the greatest players
Dan so as a as a fan I know I'm up here
in the commentary Booth but I just like
to think I have the best seat in the
house because that was pure
entertainment we certainly do and
obviously it takes two to tango it takes
two to produce a match of this level and
unfortunately for hikaro fans he was not
quite able to come back but he played an
epic match we will have ficaro for an
interview in just a couple of minutes
send over your chat
[Music]
questions
well we are back with Grandmaster hikaro
Nakamura fortunately he came up short in
the SEC final but it was an amazing
performance nonetheless in this match as
well as in the SEC overall hikaro we
really appreciate you uh joining us for
an interview we won't keep you too long
could you start by sharing your overall
Reflections on that final segment of the
match you mean the one plus one or the
final
game the one well perhaps
both oh okay yeah so I mean f first
things first you know I I think um in
the in the bullet portion it started off
quite well me I won the first game um
but you know in the next couple of games
I didn't really get positions where I
felt like the flow the moves didn't seem
super easy for me and Magnus used his
time extremely well um so I mean he
built this Advantage then then you know
at the end I was able to win the second
second to last game um and this last
game unfortunately I I didn't use my
time I had like 30 seconds I guess at
the end but you know we were both moving
so fast there that I wasn't able to stop
myself and um Magnus found this great
double Rook sacrifice um you know to
save the game and uh it's what it is but
it was extremely close and I think
considering the start I'm I'm pretty
happy with the match
overall and hikaro I mean I'm sure that
most of us know the answer to this but
this is obviously just not another match
for you I mean the chance to compete
against Magnus in the SEC finals I think
everyone basically predicted that would
be the case but when you go up against
Magnus in the final like this I mean
what does it mean to you competing
against him and obviously a chance to uh
you know the lifetime score Magnus was
speaking about that not sure if you were
listening the interview as well yeah I
mean you know I think um yeah I I think
to to look at the match as a whole it
was very close there were probably two
moments when the match probably could
have gone either way I mean in a big
Direction um I would say that the start
I don't think either of us were super
super great definitely scrambles we we
weren't playing well but Magnus did
start off very fast and um there was
this critical game I I don't remember
what what which game it was but he was
up by two or three and then he had this
mouse slip then I didn't take the piece
then we ended up in this very long rook
and Bishop versus Rook game and you know
I think if Magnus had saved this game
there's a very good chance it could have
gone completely in his Direction um and
then the other moment was when I was up
by three after the break I basically
just had a sort of I don't know if you
want to call it a brain slip or a hand
slip where I put the bishop on B5
instead of going to C4 like i' had been
doing the whole match after he played
Knight six on move two and I wasn't
really able to reel it back in that game
and I think if I if in that game I had
just played Bishop C4 and what what I
was playing throughout the match I think
there was a very good chance I could
have run away with with it but those are
really the only two moments when I think
it could have gone bigly in either
direction after that I think it was just
it was a dog fight and um I mean it was
very close so you know I I think Magnus
said he wasn't happy with his play I
actually wasn't super happy with my play
throughout the match either but you know
it is what it
is hiari your rivalry with Magnus
Carlson is now extended to the better
part of a decade if you had to compare
the sort of stereotypical Nakamura
Carlson match from 2016 and take one
from 2022 or 2023 how do you feel that
your and magnus's styles and approach
particularly to Blitz and bullet have
changed over the
years well I mean first things first for
all for all the morons in chat who are
busy saying stupid things they be happy
to hear me say this but um you know what
I what I would say first and foremost is
that frankly it was not a rivalry until
probably the pandemic if I'm being
completely honest I me Magnus had a
great score against me he won pretty
much every match I would say that we
played like he won the SEC in 2016 and
um so you know Magnus just just had a
great score against so I think saying
it'si rivalry is a little bit sort of
questionable because it was very very
one-sided but certainly since the
pandemic began uh I've done a lot better
overall against him and um so I think
it's fair to say that now it is pretty
close to rivalry because it's like even
today if if you were to take this match
after the first few games and go back
five years I would have completely
folded and lost this match um and it
would have been a complete disaster so
you know it's it's I'm really happy with
the way that I played against m Magnus
uh obviously today you know he he was
just simply a little bit better at the
critical moments but you know I had my
chances and I I think when you're
playing against you know whether you
want to call Magnus the greatest or
second greatest you know all all that
that whole debate um you know he is one
of the two best players of all time and
the fact that I'm able to compete with
him you know I'm very
happy yeah well uh hikaro obviously this
match didn't go the way you wanted but I
guess I was just going to ask you if you
had any final thoughts about uh you know
the match overall or anything else you
wanted to say uh here because appreciate
you coming on for an
interview yeah I mean the there are a
couple things I mean the the first thing
that I would say is you know there all
these people who think they seem to
realize that times don't change people
don't change and um you know like if
this had been a match like maybe like
five six years ago I'd probably be very
very upset right now honestly um but the
fact that it was so close uh All Things
Considered I'm I'm very happy I guess my
my only regret is I wish I could have
flipped the bullet chest championship in
this event like I would have preferred
to lost that and won the SEC rather than
the other way around um but nonetheless
you know I'm I'm I'm just very happy
that I'm competitive with Magnus overall
and um you know it's it's been it's been
a lot of fun playing sec I mean I I
guess like the the only thing that I
find a little bit dis disheartening or
disappointing is it feels like you know
he's the only other player where it's
it's really really close uh it seems
like whenever he or I play other players
in SEC it it turns into these these very
uh ugly one-sided matches um so that's
that's the only thing perh I wish like
some other players would would would
come up and and and be in be in the
matches um but you know overall like
again to for for the match to be so
close I mean literally one game to be
the differential I could have gone
either way and I mean I suspect uh when
we have have some fun matchups coming up
in the near future uh it'll be pretty
hype as
well well hiar I think I speak for all
of us when I say that you gave us 3
hours of Unforgettable entertainment and
obviously a new page and a new chapter
is still remaining to be written in your
uh Affair against Magnus Carlson we look
forward to that new chapter and we
really really appreciate you coming on
to share your
thoughts no problem you guys have a good
one thanks have a good rest of your
stream and that was hikaro Nakamura that
is all she wrote himan he loses by a
point last year he won by a point and I
think I can Echo hikaru's words when I
say that these two players are the only
ones who are able to put together a
match against the other no one else came
even close against either hikaro or
Magnus is it a surprise that we had a
one-point match yeah I think um you know
it's always refreshing to hear both of
these players just pure raw honest
thoughts I I I thought both interviews
were really interesting to hear their
perspectives and probably the most
interesting thing is what hearu said at
the end just calling it like it is uh
this match is always close no matter
which way Direction it swings in it's
always close but you don't get that uh
sense of intrigue and competitiveness
necessarily with all the other players
so you know what what can you say it's
like uh um problems for being uh that
good at the game Daniel I I can't even
imagine the nerves and the pressure that
these players feel and Magnus Carlson
was world champion for 10 years the
neither of these players is a stranger
to high pressure situations but we've
talked about it players of all talked
about it in the SEC and in these
prestigious online events it's a
different kind of pressure feeling that
there are 150,000 Souls watching your
every move that produces an incredible
amount of heat on the players and the
way that they handle this as we look now
at the final bracket very sad am on
unfortunately all of the names have been
filled out and that means the SEC has
come to a close but man oh man was it an
epic journey to the top for both of
these players and an epic journey to the
throne for Magnus Carlson yeah barring a
last second Karu Rook A2 check and
Checkmate combination to send us into TI
BRS it couldn't have gotten any better
than this what a what a fitting way to
end the SEC uh your Champion is
Grandmaster Magnus Carlson and uh we got
the final that I think everyone was
hoping for and I think you said it best
just at the end there Danel there are
future chapters to be written in this
storied rivalry and I think we are
to call it a rivalry especially now
between these two as just a point has
decided things between them and they're
just the greatest competitors for a
reason a book will be written on uh
magnus's matches against diar Nakamura a
book can already be written about the
back and forth that we have seen every
time that they play whether it's in the
bullet chest championship in Fisher
random any variant choose a Time control
it doesn't matter Yaro and Magnus always
produce the kind of incredible
entertaining chess that has made chess a
spectator sport beyond a shadow of doubt
we saw that today and not only is it a
spectator sport but it's a sport that
can now support uh its top earners as we
take a look at the prize distribution
from the speed Chess Championship almost
50,000 for Magnus remember this is a
composite of the matches that he won as
well as the points that he has garnered
so all of those blowout victories was
not lost on the bankers Yaro with 30,000
a pretty handsome prize as well that's a
nice car and we see the other RIS is
there everybody gets something but
Magnus Carlson picks up the big pot
indeed and I think uh you know the most
exciting thing for the speed Chess
Championship is you know I liked it you
put Magnus on the spot and said hey will
we see you you know in the SEC again I
think the most exciting thing to hear
from Magnus himself was that uh you know
say what you want but the guy is not
satisfied he he thinks and knows that he
can do better so you know until he's
scoring against Hikaru Nakamura which
seems Unthinkable until he's scoring
like he did against Wesley against
Hikaru it seems like he's just he can't
be satiated so from that point of view
it seems like we may write quite a few
chapters of this uh Hikaru and Magnus
match in the future and that is a good
news for the SEC it is indeed you see
this in all the greatest athletes in the
world it doesn't matter if they've just
won Wimbledon the FIFA World Cup the NBA
Championship the first thing they do is
ask where did I go wrong how could I
have been better how do I be better next
time right it's not about celebrating
the victory they drive themselves to
Perfection for their entire chess career
and that is how they come the closest of
anybody to attaining that Perfection
well this match was Perfection and if
you're already experiencing withdrawal I
wanted to remind you that the chess
calendar never sleeps and it will awaken
once again uh this weekend when we head
back to school uh with the 2023
Collegiate chess League fall season we
return with Team Blitz matches every
Saturday featuring the top talent in
American college chess and it all kicks
off tomorrow tomorrow Saturday September
the 23rd of course there's also bullet
brawl there is plenty of action tune in
wherever you watch chess.com streams and
use exclam CCL that's exclamation mark
CCL in the chat for everything you need
to know about the season well we know
everything we need to know about the SEC
I'm on for the final time today I will
hand the mic back to you for your
overall thoughts on today's match and
yet another epic season of the speed
Chess
Championship it is I I think the SEC
never disappoints um and despite having
an inkling or maybe having a a
preference uh for some of the fans out
there they're thinking oh I just want to
see Magnus and he Caro play in the final
it was never a guarantee that that they
would be there but they're both on form
both completely deserving uh to be in
the final and they didn't just get to
the to the final and uh and face off
against each other they gave the fans
literally exactly what they were
chomping at the bit for a lead from both
players momentum swings attacks like
crazy hikaro was going after magnus's
King today some really exciting chests
tons of brilliancies and literally down
to the final game Dan I mean not only
could I not think of a better match to
commentate in the in the final but not a
better partner either so happy to have
the call with you Daniel
well I'm very touched Aman and likewise
it takes an entire Village and first and
foremost I'd like to thank you for your
wit and your Insight and just being such
an easy partner to work with uh next I'd
like to thank everybody in the chat we
had over 125,000 of you and the great
thing about the SEC everybody comes out
with a smile on their face whether
you're a hikaro fan a Magnus fan or
whether you were hoping for an
outstanding performance by someone else
in the field we all have to come
together for a second and agree that
there was no better way to spend the
previous 3 hours our production team
works so hard behind the scenes our
producer holla uh for an incredible job
yet again and everybody else on our
chess.com team for being responsible for
these amazing broadcasts and making our
jobs easy folks the CCL returns this
weekend the SEC returns next year and a
big big thank you once again from
Grandmaster Daniel nitki and Grandmaster
ran Hamilton you were watching the speed
chest Championship presented by coinbase
So Long by
guys Bishop for itself was so bad rookie
seven oh he oh my goodness he drops a
minor piece and Magnus strikes first
after that initial draw wait a minute
Rook G check Rook GH check what a move
oh wow wow oh Rook takes three though oh
and Rook takes G3 blundered his Queen
Magnus blundered his Queen he can't
cover with the Knight and he car wins
unbelievable this game went up in Flames
oh my gosh there's a queen sack
on oh oh my goodness that is beautiful
wow just wow oh no oh no oh no oh no
there's only one move in that position
and nobody could produce it no he can't
believe it Magnus is like how did this
just happen if the King was on D4
different why did oh he's got his King
tap six and Magnus he has lost a
critical game allowing Magnus to tie the
match up to E4 potentially and Magnus is
a gr he Mouse slipped what was that what
are you doing you've got 15 seconds taru
doing everything he can to open up
White's King but I think Magnus has
enough just like that Magnus flips the
script oh my goodness Rook A2 he missed
it oh my gosh am on hikaro had first
mate and it's a drop by agreement these
guys are just two Titans two Champions
going at one
[Music]
another
[Applause]
[Music]
he